everybody Welcome to the H3
podcast bald
Edition today is
October
9th yes sir what the heck I wasn't it
just September like on
Friday I feel like I did a time where
man FR so first of all um thank you to
everybody on Friday the subathon was a
massive success yes thank you guys for
all your support
and yes the funnest part was actually
just that we made a really great show
out of it and everyone seemed to be
having fun yeah which makes me really
excited to make this like an annual
thing M and I'm thinking next year next
year Staples Center Staple Center just
me drunk in the middle of Staples Center
uh it's called The crypto.com Arena now
by the way I will never say that yeah
that's like calling Twitter X it's not
happening yeah
right um so thank you everybody very
very very
grateful to everybody who Could That did
become a member and I'm grateful to
everyone who watched too because uh
listen all love it's all it's all family
all this this this is why I'm watching
thank you
uh thank
you
um yeah I mean again we get to keep the
show free forever live shows every show
it's all free you know we're not doing
that oh get the next pay me for the next
hour no I'm a man of the people I
thought it was free you know what I
mean you do do a bonus episode on
Tuesday though it's not really a bonus
episode okay well I mean it's not an
episode of this show right it is kind of
just me you know doxing yourself hours
your yeah at sometimes it's just an hour
right but most all the time it's fun
right it's just a little incentive for
the members a a token of appreciation to
anyone who wants to watch it's not a
full epis it's not really a podcast the
real value it's literally just me
sitting at my computer the real value is
the credit card yeah yes not the content
a lot of value on but also there is
another thing that we do that I believe
makes us fantastic and people men of the
people we
clip from the members don't we we do we
do when there's a funny topic on the
member stream I put it up on Highlights
come there's the clip go look for the
clip no one else does that nobody cares
about the people like I do right folks
that's right anyway um is Cam okay Chad
is asking is Cameron okay no you said no
that bad no I'm fine um yeah no I was
fine the next day I didn't have any
hangover I threw up a lot um he purged
it all I have a funny story about the
worst part of the night um so I was
vomiting a lot everyone was so so
gracious and checking in on me all night
thank you guys very much um the real
issue was that I didn't drank too much I
did just ate too little but the worst
part of the night was when AB came in
and checked on me he said cam is there
anything I can get you I said yes my
friend AB I love you so much I can
always relying you can you please get me
something with electrolytes in it so he
runs out he comes back in he's he does
his job he does it perfectly I just
didn't specify he brings me back in
Logan Paul Prime oh disgusting smart man
this is going to sounds like a joke but
it's not this is AB St kill with the
prime what actually happened AB what the
bro no this is all we had for
electrolytes in the office so he comes
in he gives me the prime I take one sip
of that and I'm serious I
immediately started vomiting way
more that is disgusting listen I
was taking care of multiple people who
were drunk
no and I uh it was the first thing I saw
was
like this good get the on Prime AB
was probably or you and Lena were the
only sober people here as far as I can I
can't remember anything and ab gave me a
ride home that night too so thank you
very much problem oh nice yeah AB there
you go champion of the people as well
and uh yeah so I I started vomiting from
Prime and I as I was finished I poured
that into the toilet with it and
flushed it it's actually good you did
that because Prime the big Scandal is
that it's really formulated so horribly
it's not really an electrolyte drink it
just has a ton of
magnesium but what it needs is sodium to
be an electrolyte yeah who somebody made
a video All About That Game Theory made
one there's been a few frankly oh okay
uh seen some other videos from like a
you know food scientist Matt Pat that's
that's why people like oh yeah Matt Pat
he did a whole expose on Logan dude wait
mat the game theory guy yes he did sh no
I'm not doubting you I'm just yeah he's
of of streamy Fame yeah YouTube Tau his
night that's all I can he has another
Channel called the food theorist okay
that makes more sense I was like what
does that have to do with like a video
game wait he has a whole Channel about
theories about food the food theorist
surely that doesn't make sense why' you
need a new funnel for that bro passion
project passion okay well hold on let me
pull it up okay whatever I'm over it so
anyway uh that's actually really
interesting to know thanks for sharing
that cam it tastes almost immediately
exactly that is good to know merely
coincidence you know um let's see how's
everybody else doing uh did anyone else
get super trashed cuz I don't really
remember love you were there with me
right I don't remember either so yes I I
did get trashed you love and cam were on
one tier and then I think Olivia and I
were on the next TI and then ab and Lena
and I and were all they were on they
were on Earth yeah so I matched you I
don't remember I had like one beer okay
so it's basically down on her he's a
good man yeah I matched you completely
and after the show on Friday we talked
about what we didn't remember and it
linked up exactly cuz I think I drank
right when you drank so I have the same
kind of black black this is what I'll
say I have never blacked out in my
life until I I don't I I'm my I don't
know what it is but I can't drink
heavily usually I'll puke I'll just feel
nauseous and sick but something happened
on
Friday I didn't feel I didn't feel
nauseous the whole night I didn't puke I
was fine I Saturday but Patrone baby
how's that how was that possible I and
there's so many things I don't remember
like people were putting up clips of
whatever Ethan drunk Mega compilation
and so much of it I don't remember which
is really weird for me um
but but I guess it was entertaining
right know very episode did great
everybody seemed to have a good time uh
yeah I think it was how were you feeling
the morning after I didn't feel great
but I didn't feel that bad either did
you drink a lot of water at night yeah I
drank water I mean I I don't it was just
weird like I went home I slept for 2
hours on the couch and then I got up and
I wasn't tired anymore weird night man
yeah right it's the biggest trick of
night of the year here's a steeven thank
you it it sure is uh here's a seven
minute compilation I guess of me being
drunk let's see was anyone impressed
with
my knowledge on like how did I do on
those things uh knowledge you did pretty
good
nice how' I do on female anatomy I think
not bad I think you did better than many
of us expected yeah nice yeah
vagina you were also very sympathetic
which was very kind yeah yeah he's an
empath what can you say he's an empath
literally he would never himself girl
girl that's right I am feminist Queen so
anyway here it is uh let's jog my
memory one na G with extra beef extra
okay I got home and I was like I didn't
eat any today then I was like wait I was
eating like a lot wait I just realized
you wanted us to pop quiz you it may be
best to do that first pop quiz me I have
it okay let's do the quiz first because
once you watch this it's going to
refresh your memory about a lot so you
all put together a pop quiz yeah to see
what I remember huh very fun I can pull
it up if you want just cuz I have time
stamps in there sure where is it uh guys
I'll tell you what I'm not going to
drink again the whole year until next
year here subathon once a year for you
guys only one night show one
man one bottle of Patron right it's the
biggest trick in of the year that was it
call Dan on the on the
um The Patrone Blanco
yeah why I'm telling you that's some
good tequila clean um all right so and
this is the first question is actually
what just made me think of this what did
you order from Bell and did you eat
here's the thing I watched some of the
clips and this is the only reason I
remember but I got a naturo bell grande
you remember extra cheese and extra beef
right yes you did yes did it did on that
yeah it was it looked pretty cheesy and
beefy
bro see can we see
it guess hidden behind all this
did I eat anything else that night
than the Taco Bell we had Mickey D's in
the morning we did eat it the very
beginning that's right so I think you
found the ice cream I right I saw a clip
oh you did eat ice cream and at the end
of the stream like after all of that you
go all I've had today is an Egg
McMuffin like we just watched you eat
that's how I felt when I got home okay
so I've got the grand yeah uh so the
second question is did we watch the Tik
talk Alpha
bro so I don't
remember I know I've seen people doing
memes about how I guess I kept
mentioning it is that what happened I
saw a funny post and I'm assuming it was
a joke they said why wouldn't Dan watch
let Ethan watch the alpab
bro uh yeah we did watch it and uh not
only did we watch it but then about an
hour later you started talking about it
as if we hadn't watched it and when we
tried to correct you you were adamant
that we that we were gaslighting you and
that we hadn't watched it oh no my boys
said this come on Jake uh do you know
which is number three number five number
five food right and so this specifically
you were like pull up the Africa video
Pull up the Africa video and this is us
watching it the first time and much
later you were very insistent well this
is just the first time so it's not but
the point is that yes we watched it said
this to me they said they were concerned
for me and they didn't like what I was
doing all right what was the uh what was
the highest that you blew on the breath
Al life
okay that I
don't uh he blew it yeah how did you
blow it I don't know like a 1.6 I
remember something like that
interesting okay so that actually is
correct and why that is so fascinating
is that at the
time no no no it it says 1.6 on it but
then he says something completely
different oh because you guys don't
understand how my brain works I'm
dyslexic when I see it I know what it
says right but when what you say when
what I say is what I think I see in my
brain we're smelling the breath we're
analyzing it we're waxing the GU
1.68 that's good that's a good is that
good 1.68 oh it did say 1.68 the other
way around is that high though cuz I oh
it's six yeah yeah 06 okay right right
so you just got the decimal so
it's 68 is that high cuz it didn't seem
that high to me and the level I was so
freaking blasted driving is
8 that's it so as I was half as drunk I
could drive drive angry that should be
illegal question yeah well I mean
alcohol is very uh subjective and you
don't drink almost ever and so I'm not
surprised that you did you blow more I
don't know no clue I don't remember
anything wine sorry I remember you did
blow I blew a couple times um does
anyone know I the highest I got was
.13 he blew it how can it be like how
can it be that's not that big of a
difference is it for me well it's also
it depends on like if you're a
lightweight versus not it does yeah yeah
that's what I'm saying it's like you
don't you don't drink ever so you don't
have like any so maybe that's why I
didn't get sick and all that I just got
I'm a cheap date well you drink a lot I
feel like I did drink a lot no I it is
impressive that you held that down thank
you so much um all right so uh next
question what happened to the podium
again that's a clip I saw I didn't
remember it in the morning but something
I don't remember what happened but I
remember kicking it over and I'm glad I
didn't Hur anybody let's move on let's
move on to number two he can't do
anything right now yeah I don't remember
this I do want to I want to point out
that Ethan did just break the podium
Podium what how how did so you leaned
against it really hard and it snapped
there and then and
then
the podium fat shamed
me bringing old trauma back I heard it I
heard it you know it's a kind it kind of
deserved it yeah it's a Podium I lean on
it and break it give me a break yeah
what killed me is when you were doing
the Nathaniel Clansman I was sitting up
there cuz you kept leaning on the podium
and I thought you were going to break it
before that but because I was sitting up
there you started to talk directly to me
and you you had your eyes closed looking
right at me and I I didn't want to
up your groove but I didn't want to be
rude either but I was kind of looking
away I don't think I was looking at you
I think I was there was a point where
you were like I don't know you're really
into character but it's possible I don't
remember it is possible I was staring
deep into ab's beautiful eyes who's at
the podium here his beautiful ambers let
me see those eyes his beautiful baby
ambers are those are those what would
you say those are AB Hazel yeah wait
yeah not Amber Hazel Hazel okay Bragg
you think you're Hazel he's definitely
Hazel I know I'm ha he's as Hazel as I
am no he's not not look at those Dan
look at those eyes who could see who
could those are blue
they're Hazel they're blue Hazel we've
gone over this go on all right next
question uh why did I have such a hard
time shaving your
eyebrows probably cuz I was just moving
a
lot
mhm you remember the specifics of
why my eyebrows three reasons there's
there's kind of three distinct reasons
that made it I had three uh difficulty
handicaps
here I guess you you'd have a hard time
guessing it's I don't remember you look
stressed right now well for one you were
very drunk okay two your Tourette's was
was kicking up and you explained that to
you said Dan listen I have something
called Tourette's syndrome and then
third you also had the hiccups at the
time oh the hiccup that again that is
never happen like dodging God we
even well I'll say this Dan you did a
really good job very thorough oh I don't
even I don't know you did I I guess we
got there eventually but no you did I
was just I was very paranoid cuz I had
this buzzer like inches from your eye
and you're like going like this
constantly you did great really you did
especially on the Dome I mean it's clean
okay yeah yeah well I have some
experience with that absolutely I tell
bra smashed uh and then finally
um last question at one point evening
you and Olivia sang a duet do you
remember what sang No you don't
remember I remember I saw a clip Daniel
right that's right that's right wasn't
there another one no I think it was just
that I don't think so but in the future
there will be I assume there'll be more
yeah you were singing Allison oh yeah by
Elvis costell right right Alison was
here okay okay and that's it so not bad
obviously some gaps in your memory but
uh you you did decent I remember just
having a ton of cake
Puffs that was Alison Allison brought
cake pops he brought so many why did I
have so many I had like eight of
them I didn't notice that to be honest
so many cake pops there was like bags on
bags on bags yeah I feel like she came
when I started kind of getting really
drunk and she left before I sobered up
so I was like was she here it was a BL I
Have Cake Pops I don't really know
what's going on can you ask her if she's
watching or if she's I want to know how
many cake pops did she bring oh that's
CU it must have been a gang I remember
just flash like an overing amount that's
what I remember no she did come in with
like a full Starbucks bag full of
individual cake pop bags I looked
through all of them not was I had I had
five cake pops to myself God like I
would not be surprised if it was upwards
of 20 cake pops for real more more they
are pretty good aren't they it was
really fun though I I actually I'll be
honest it was a fun night it was a fun
night I agree it was a wholesome night
and the good thing is since we have did
we ever hit the button yes yes were they
good were they clean good buttons like
required buttons yeah um actually only
one of them was required and it really
wasn't that bad but it was just getting
a little borderline the thing is the and
then I remember I think the second one
was somebody hitting it as a
joke I'm so happy the button is here
because you know when you get that drunk
and you're live oh brother you just you
never know you were talking about uh
something about Michael Jackson and you
said something that was a little like
eyebrow raising oh I remember we just H
it we hit it out of an abundance of
caution it was right right right right
right you were I must say you were were
being a very good boy yeah you were you
were on good behavior for how drunk you
were thank you you're just like very
like happy drunk for the most I tend to
be a happy drunk except for except for
when you smash the podium yeah I don't
know why just F I always think that it's
funny to like get like to break things
Ben or not benevolent to get um it's
like how do you how would you describe
it benign violence right yeah Ben
violence like a giant toddler stom I
find it funny it's funny I thought I
think but yeah I I I I tend to be that
way so I'm happy that that's the way it
went so thank you everybody um here
let's watch this I
guess L sorry l i I didn't mean to I
don't know why I was yelling that was
not cool I want it's always bad to watch
yourself drunk isn't it my head it's all
in good fun I remember thinking like um
I remember
thinking
that I was like I don't think
I'm I don't think I'm I don't think the
show's entertaining I'm just sitting
here
drunk but I don't think that was what it
was no we had all kinds of thing
activities and things and it was
entertaining it was entertaining yeah it
was fun certainly oh my
[Laughter]
God this was a Vibe for sure I remember
this before appreciate the way that you
said
[Music]
um that the I didn't know I did this
squinty eye thing I I was watching a
clip where my eye was just like this
yeah look at that I was telling you look
like Bush all night I was like this for
like an hour okay popy
style we're not brand friendly cuz I
talk I do bomb threats and stuff like
that and I am just
say stop don't do it Che my brothers I
don't care you what color you
n Michael Jackson said he said I don't
care if you're black or blue or purple I
said mother who's purple I never met no
purple I don't know what
that even means my hair is like a damn
wool what's that really delicate wool
that's really expensive cashmir I have
cashmere
hair idiot he a drunk and idiot loser
all right here we go oh will this bird
looks like that bird please oh
this bird looks like that bird sh idiot
that was me talking about Darwin yeah
yeah that's
disrespectful that was fat you know hair
cutters they have a they do a good way
do good in this world they make good
[Music]
money my blood alcohol is 100% I ain't
got no blood left it's just alcohol did
you have any water water here drink
water yeah I'll drink drink water I
haven't had water I don't remember
drinking water did I you I mean here
yeah uh there was a few times when you
were you have a butt you under I have I
have to tell you I I don't know if you
realized this later in the night but I
did cut you off at one point see no I I
I I don't remember that cuz you were
demanding more alcohol and I was just
like we're out that's good that's good
yeah that's good I I found this on the
floor like next to my chair it I think
someone gave it to at one point you were
laying down over there I never there was
there was a time when I like hit my Apex
I peaked uhhuh and I was coming back I
was coming getting sober I was still
trashed um and I
remember I remember there was a
conversation about how you hit it from
me right because later as you started to
sober up you were like oh I do want to
do another shot now and you were going
to drink some other alcohol which is
never a good idea to like mix type of
alcohol or whatever so rather than I was
finally like okay if you're going to
have another one stick with the same
thing so oh my God I can't 8 hours we
went that's
crazy right oh yeah Char Darwin's a
great thinker yep man went to the
galopagos island but then you say well
there's food in other places that are
really dope too for example people were
saying Ela was over it by the way she's
she has a she's been having headaches
yeah she has she's pregnant she has
headaches she's not she's sober I mean
what the she was a trooper to stick
it out she's a trooper are you kidding
me she said there for eight hours yeah
dealing with
this you know there's eight fish come
from water right so how far you back you
want to go I'm not trying to do the
Garden of
even why you going against the grain I
have no hair God damn call me Mr
Clean why going against gra can I get
the blower cuz I'm out in Jupiter
where's the
blower
feels
good can we get Alfredo some Treasures L
that's my
favorite we get in here my God why are
you doing that can somebody escort him
to the bathroom pleas good
man who was escorting was that you AB
you got it that was a good good camera
work there oh thank you my new camera I
was very impressed with it actually I
didn't I didn't know I was being
filmed I wish I had audio cuz like right
here before I let you go you said uh
you're so strong and you have such a
nice even
tan what the
well that's
crazy oshw Survivor
being that's not funny Ethan is uh
stumbling out of the bathroom he's on
his way he's doing good absolutely man
of the
hour you want a cough drop Ethan you
want a cough drop I don't remember this
I don't take it on I'm very sorry that I
did that what did I throw Addison Ray
Ray I didn't even I didn't know you had
an Addison Ray
Barbie I keep her I don't really talk
about her but that's part of what
confused me I was like I don't know
anything about it as I didn't I'm sorry
did I damage it no she's okay she uh has
like a concussion but two to three weeks
she should be good oh that's good not
too bad she's still
smiling look at that arm though good
arm where's all my hair where' all my
hair go ain't never supposed to create
with your sis now and that's the truth
how did this go I don't remember about
as well as you wouldn't end bro it
wouldn't end it would not warned you
guys and I'm sitting right in your
eyeline right now by the way let me see
true that I believe my eyes are closed I
know your eyes are closed but
occasionally I just look back and you
were like looking right at me you have
no recollection of this whatsoever no I
mean I remember that I did it but that's
it that's it also just so the audience
knows you haven't had your shoes on for
like three hours at this point well
that's fair no yeah no it's fair I just
think it's funny to add on to the no
shoes no shoes you know Ain just enough
ain't enough enough jeams r that bike
that
lower we got that tggo b what there's no
way I am like in another dimension do
you like my head baked Ela what do you
like my head baked like this this what
are you saying he expecting
a to act rationally right now sober as a
go for Ethan Klein ain't no problem here
you know I don't remember what that was
but I remember she was trying to get me
to stop doing something what was
it I don't remember you'd have to be
more specific I feel like it happened a
few times yeah
okay stand on one leg for uh 30 seconds
just problem yeah you got it no need to
hold the PO though you're going to have
to hold on why not hold on I love this
you were like doing the crane from
Karate Kid it's kind of good though for
how drunk I
was all right one more try one more try
here we go call that one a freebie right
okay all right yeah all
right I don't think have it what this is
like just girly things meme yes exactly
this is me and you AB our romance
begins if you're a ver I'm a bird right
let's go jeez baby you're free wait what
just happened I just woke up you just
woke up yo uh yeah we that is
serious I
don't I didn't you do that you could
have not done that you could have
totally not done that I might
go home I don't know well you going go
home where's that
her the time on the show you've shaved
your head of time L youir by money so wa
the next eyebrows how may far away from
that I don't understand where's my hair
at we shaved it off what 1.3 how's that
possible I can going down feel like a
cartoon character right now with the
hiccup there's a specific I remember the
hiccups it was really crazy I had no
control yeah and they were really
violent and hurt when it going like that
it was really something
specific not what the why was it open
it's good for a brother but don't pull
my head like that I have Ted syndrome
Dan don't be this is the one time makes
a huge difference so thank you to
everybody for your support I it truly
means a lot well done I appreciate the
the tender careful ha that where my
eyebrows
go take all off godam you know what I
mean
the audio button on the uh I have no
eyebrows I they're here to serve the
people if they if they get a membership
that's that's one
second oh wait here's the here's some of
the bags so here's a giant right okay it
was just a did she get back to us let me
see I got to know I got to be honest
she's probably asleep really is she a is
she a um she's nocturnal really oh big
time she works time she go to
bed uh want to out I mean I guess it's
not a big deal uh probably like 4 a.m.
to like 700 a.m. usually whoa that's
those are major that
are that's high level I'm telling you
nocturnal so yeah she's probably still
asleep wow wow wow well I'm I you know
that's my natural state of being as well
so shout out to Allison yeah that's one
that's one second
uh let's try the thing I don't
think uh it will be J soon so how long
we been oh it broke don't feel
nothing so the American Civil War is
it's really a fascinating how I do in
the Civil
War I probably it was fine no grade
required yeah they want me to call Han
Dan told me to watch the button when you
were doing the Civil War he was walking
Aly out like a gentleman and he's like
what cuz he has the button on his
computer but I could not find the button
on his computer I'm like oh I run
into the physical one just in case funny
what were you afraid I was going to say
Dan nothing specific to the Civil War I
was just hovering over the button the
whole time the N word thank that's not
what I was worried about what the
Zack what the
God damn it Christ some high level ideas
to let's not drunk dial people hey what
up what's going on did you try to call
me what did I talk to about you tried to
call me call me on this you were telling
him about wormholes oh God that was kind
of funny I tried to wave you off but you
were you were determined it and he was
he was open for it so I think he was
streaming right yeah people went over to
his stream and were like Ethan strun he
wants to talk to you oh man oh dude well
that wasn't my idea somebody said that
or maybe it was in chat yes yeah
something like that yes I know what that
means you want to talk about China and
taian or
[Laughter]
no quantum entanglement have you guys
heard about
this what it's t what am I saying do you
remember I didn't know at the time I
still don't
know have you guys heard about
this
sit what it's
sit dude you sound like a karate master
I don't know no it's not sit it's like
it said E I don't know I have no
idea what it's what the do you
remember I have no clue no clue there's
a pretty funny meme edit we have in the
dock about that moment okay I guess we
we'll almost done for throwing um
Olivia's Barbie what yeah you threw the
Addison Ray doll across the room at one
point
no I've never
seen God I must have ate a lot of ice
cream
[Music]
[Laughter]
in wow that was shout out to to Herby
Herby 2 YouTube Herby do2 uh yes thank
you so much funny man you know again the
the views were great people came they
watched they had fun and thank you to
the crew all you guys did were fantastic
uh it really was a really fun show so
overall great time I'm really happy and
so next year we'll look forward to
uh uh to another one bigger and better
okay I'm I'm getting feedback that you
were saying set it's set about what I
that I can't tell you it's set I thought
it was that's it that's it that's it
it's set wait somebody else is saying
I'm I'm pretty sure it's Ted like
shouting Ted no there's no shot I was
saying
Ted well then I the mystery oh you were
impersonating Bruce I think huh you were
saying I didn't I feel like you
explained it some of the people in chat
are saying it that Bruce says
something set not I don't know what it
is let me see if I can find it in the
episode jeez
man um here here there's a what's the
other one um there was a edit you wanted
me to watch oh the Step Brothers
one number uh letter C is this one worth
watching it's probably just a little
redundant eh yes the second one yeah
Step Brothers Let's
see it
look are you saying pal what are you
saying why does he keep doing that you
know what I'm
saying
that is the
most mysterious
part it's set it's
set it's set I wish we caught on camera
when you walked by mine and I desk and
you just slap off my desk and then
he went end and he went no it was
hilarious and he went like this on his
keyboard just like hit all the buttons
on the VX that's the benign
Mischief thing mischief's fun yeah
there's no no problem with mischief
album of memes okay all right let's
[Applause]
see um Ethan travel photo
montage wow really a special moment we
shareed a really yeah it's beautiful uh
wow Paris the
Bahamas Taj Mahal Taj mahall my goodness
the Great Wall of China we really seen
the worldwood stop why would I oh no
no looks like I'm pulling you in AB oh
no uh okay me having a moment with
alfredo who I love holding the
microphone up for yeah my
Dome I mean it's just what happens when
it tension goes on it yeah yeah you know
it's a bald Dome what do you
want come
on oh really you're going to hit me with
this I thought that I had wavy hair
until I shave instead I find I have
straight hair and a wavy
head please
dude stop it how's it started versus
how's it going this picture of Alfredo
is so D funny look at him he's perfect
how is he I mean he was here for eight
hours he's chilling
Alie a long day for a poor guy yeah uh
uh I see it okay yeah the Mexican alien
exhibit Peru right oh was Peru I thought
it was
Mexico here is uh love and Alfredo have
switched
heads what the hecking dog Ethan passes
the booth this is really good that's so
sick that's crazy good
smile watching your dad get blasted God
Alfredo is so funny he just lined up
there it's so funny he was just sitting
on my lap for forever that's good he's
sweet
boy uh me a VOD boy sing the runtime of
the subathon VOD of course being 8
hours when they ask how was the
subathon good it was good I
guess um this guy went bald same time I
saw this one on the server I got to give
a shout out cuz this guy looks he looks
way better in my opinion yeah the Dome
suits him
right hell yeah brother yeah definitely
he says I went bald at the same time as
Ethan D was a huge inspiration look at
that yeah but you didn't do it till
Ethan M right um just
saying yeah why aren't you thanking
me good point Dan no I I get his point
he you're you're a
bald confident
King right but I've been bald for years
and and then you do it once and all of a
sudden he's on board so you're saying
it's he's being disingenuous saying he's
being trendy if he right if he cared he
would have done it years ago that's
right he looks great regardless he looks
really good Ethan this
morning oh Legend has it if the
crew would have snuck out at this moment
Nathaniel would still be live today that
is very well possible if you guys all
left it might have taken me a
moment uh Charles Darwin was a drunk and
an idiot loser 5 minutes later Charles
Joan's a genius love that little drawing
this is this I would never do oh no AB I
would never do this me leading him into
the Church of
Scientology I love that the Barack meme
was pretty
iconic that is really
[Music]
good the podcast Dragon my ass out of
depression every time there's a new
episode well that's well thank you very
nice thank you so much it's our it's our
honor and our
privilege to uh to spend these times
with you guys so I thank you all very
much for for being there with us really
is just incredible thank you guys so
much Lena was a enabler she she was the
only one that was uh telling you where
the remaining alcohol was we all hit it
you mean doing my job that's right he
was asking just replying he that's yeah
I got your back I thought my mic was
muted I said in Arabic what are you
trying to do I stand behind l
I stand with Lena thank you guys
absolutely I stand with you Lena no
matter what for real I got your back no
matter what there it is whatever choice
you would have made I would have stood
with you and against
AB me
too anyone
else uh this
CH
kidding uh this is let's
see wait we owe 40 5
minutes are you serious we didn't do all
the time yeah so the uh the timer froze
for like a 12 minute period of time and
it's uh oh
there we go sorry I'm switching
right now um yeah so the timer froze for
about 12 minutes and in that 12 minutes
we gain something like 3,000 something
Subs which equals out to 45 minutes or
so what so we were supposed to go 45
minutes longer holy
yep whoa that would have been too much
that would have been like yeah and then
over 45 you get more that we've been
there for like 10 hours man be the yeah
45 would probably be two hour two hours
actually it's crazy wow well that's I
guess I'm kind of glad that happened to
be honest but thank you guys we owe them
though we do owe you I don't know how I
can possibly pay you back we can start
the next year's with 45 minutes on the
clock yeah that's fair oh interesting
that is that's probably the most Fair
way to do it pay
forward otherwise you could just do a
long membersip or something God we got
to really figure something crazy out
like rent a warehouse and set up all
kinds of crazy ball pits and and
monkey bars let's do it with Mr Beast
let's get Beast involved
he'll he'll uh he's good at kind of ping
people that's what I
He he'll keep water from me until I can
successfully walk a tight
rope or something you know just normal
stuff uh here is my parents is hanging
out I found out my dad smoked crack
actually one time and I'm not the only
one actually there's a lot of people who
are onetime crack smokers and I think
that's special I think that's something
that we should celebrate and honor
cracker uh they were talking about
cocaine I don't remember why and I was
like I for sure my mom is going to be
panicked when I tell her this even
though I've said it like a thousand
times did you I've smoked crack
once cuz I smoked crack one time did you
smoked crack once so genuinely wored CRA
never never anyone else you ever tried
crack once once that's what it's
about you smoked crack once happen never
C well well I so
thoughtful you're not taking this are
you I was like who's going to Care you
guys who's going to
Care
Gary crackhead smoker there you go I
guess I know where I got my crack
Affinity
from uh there's another Ace family scam
this is exciting what are we cooking up
here Austin
It's actually an amazing opportunity oh
good gamed I've actually been looking
for one of those and best part no risk
like you won't believe this
what's up y'all real quick PSA
whoever's interested on making quick
easy money from home on your phone all
you got to do is hit up my friend Zab
she's one of the best Forex traders in
the game I'll put her tag right here
I've been recently doing some small
Investments with her and seeing a return
within 24 hours she's willing to do the
same same with you guys so for example
if you put in 200 or 500 bucks or 1,000
bucks you'll see a quick return within
24 hours worst case she's willing to
refund you guys you will see a quick
return in 24
hours what that sounds great bro I need
yo I need to double my money
tonight money so it sounds like a
no-brainer so if you put in 200 bucks
and you don't make any money she'll just
give you back your 200 bucks like again
yeah that's not happening dude you're
scumbag man it's a no-brainer so hit her
up right now she's only interested in
working with a few people so get in
while you can't that's iconic only a few
people what is that
car uh that looks like a Lamborghini
truck but I could be mistaken bro don't
tell me he's getting more what is he
doing is he making money what have they
been up to just like I haven't heard
from them in a minute let's let's do a
followup on them right now let's let's
let's check up on the ace family yeah
how are they doing it's been too long
too
long hey Ace Ace family three months so
it's been a minute answering all the
questions but then what are they
doing what are you guys even doing right
now Katherine's Instagram I bet she's
popping let's see Austin's
Instagram see Katherine is huh what
this is linked on their YouTube
channel her in be I have it okay wow
nice SEO
guys made I suggest does Ryan kavanau
look like Harvey wein for the next
hyperlink okay 7 million let's see when
was this posted Yos July 9 wow oh wow
she's Mia where'd they go cuz it's got
half a million likes that's pretty
serious bro you are not
flexing this is from a giveaway hey Ace
family we're doing a giveaway
Katherine's very on Tesla you're giving
away her used
card really this is weird right we're
giving up 3 months left in our lease
right tag two friends in the comments
download the app
Kick oh God god seriously
kick follow us on wait they're on Kick
follow us on kick
yo they would be pull that oh kick just
keeps
winning oh my goodness gracious that's
so interesting are they really on Kick
right now I don't think so our first
stream June 11 at 400
p.m. family that's old they haven't done
anything wow
wow what about Tik Tok it's not even
like popping up for me when I search for
Ace family unkick there it is um let's
see go to kick follow us there make sure
to tune in to our first live stream on
Kick tomorrow
idiot so wait how do you win don't miss
our giveaway announcement on live oh I I
sent the article it uh what's the
chances they actually gave that Tesla
away like be
real they go hey what come watch our
live we'll just say the winner wait
somebody in the chat don't don't know if
this is verified but they are suggesting
they gave the car to a fan they
knew a what oh here you go here's the
article let's just read
this oh um where where' you send it you
have it oh this is it a family accused
of scamming fans by handpicking winner
Tesla giveaway do you have any doubt
that they would do that no like what we
know of the ace family that yeah they
don't get the benefit of the doubt at
this point giving it away would be the
shock of a Lifetime right they I might
really start selling the clout pill you
should brother uh June 11th Austin
McBroom and cther McBroom the ace family
announced they were giving away her car
again
weird uh simly all fans had to do
participate was tag Two Friends download
Kick and follow them
there excuse
me kick kick and in the provided terms
and conditions they explicitly stated
the winner will be drawn at random on
June 25th Austin further reiterated this
point in a follow-up kick live stream
however fans have since accused the
couple of riging the giveaway pointing
to another kick live stream and claiming
the couple actually handpicked the
winner rather than committing to a
random drawing Hello of course they
did when it came to picking out the
Tesla winner ended up being actually
easier than we thought oh was this one
of the ones like the nek boys where it's
like the winner in this worldwide say
sounds exactly it's right around the
corner from me
yeah uh the the reason I say this is
because we literally had like two other
guys along with us looking for somebody
who is really part of the ace family we
got really fresh because we don't that's
not the terms and conditions you you
stated already God I want a car God why
don't why don't people get in trouble
for this like you're breaking the law
this is
fraud they don't know that but this is
fraud this is like a
felony um disagrees right maybe it's
just false advertising I don't know
let's think of how to dig ourselves out
of this
fraud we get really frustrated because
we don't know if you know the person is
like part of the ace family we don't
know if somebody really comes on who
doesn't really know us bro do I need to
go back and read the terms of your
service dumbass
loser um Austin went on to claim the
winner that was picked was one of the
first fans to buy their
merch this particular person our team
actually did their homework and
researched on this person bro what are
you
saying the person was one of the uh I
said
that uh the kick live stream was meant
to properly announce the winner however
the winner was never publicly announced
nor have either Austin or Catherine
posted about the winner on their social
media page
since holy they family has been
accused in the past of scamming yeah we
know they never said the winner even the
name holy
man
wow that's wild and yet still 400,000
people liked it that's
crazy so apparently Austin still posting
let's
see there they are they're still living
it up y'all I don't know how but there
out there
how 4 days ago cheers to a new home good
health and more
blessings and they're also coming back
says in the comments
there why do they keep moving just
curious I know
why they're getting foreclosed on
they're scamming they're being
sued where does it say they're coming
back Ops we're back on YouTube soon yeah
Austin is also posting on Snapchat oh he
probably gets paid a lot oh that's how
he's making money yeah man Snapchat
for that stop saying that first of all I
couldn't get on that Snapchat program
and then you have scumbags like David do
and Austin MC broom making like a
billion dollars a day there what the
dude nobody nobody will work with
me yet Austin McBroom a prolific scammer
this man is is getting deals I I don't
understand this industry Snapchat I
don't understand
it you know it's
crazy here they are I guess I don't know
what this is supposed to be on the way
to a decade with you okay we love we
stand
uh Happy marriages I
guess all
right very good
there they are that's what they're up to
still scamming
actively here look they just literally
did a scam like
a month ago almost two months ago
it's
awesome really a
month ah really a month I know it
it's not that long is
it not that
long so what is this one
then oh yeah the investment one
one so guys let's get over let's contact
his girl um Z one the best Forex traders
in the game dude I'll makeing quick easy
money on your phone all you got to do is
hit up my friend Zay she's one of the
best for shers in the game zay's got you
covered brother Selena's sister's name
zanb the way Z Zan Z zanab yeah huh but
the way he's saying it he has no idea
who this girl is oh it's zanab it's the
same name yeah oh I see I see he doesn't
even know who she is yeah he doesn't
know she cuz he oh you're right
that's really funny zanab trades FX he's
not saying it right oh you're so right
all you got to do is hit up my friend
zap she's one of the best
Z oh my God he's saying her name wrong
he doesn't know her
no that's special that's
lovely TR in the game I'll put her tag
right here I've been recently doing some
small Investments with her and seeing a
return within 24 hours she will to do
the same with you guys so for example if
you put in 200 or 500 bucks or 1,000
bucks you'll see a quick return 24 hours
worst case she's wor dude that's crazy I
don't need a loan anymore yeah I have an
infinite money hack thanks to Zane
AB Zane AB actually I think you said
yeah this guy really he sees his
audience members
as they're just pocketbooks I mean
they're marks they're marks yeah damn
there it is man YouTube's a hell of a
place except for at Ace Fest where they
did give back to their fans Wholesome
Way and God I had so much fun when's the
next one when's a Fest 2 do you think it
was a success for them I don't I don't I
don't know couldn't have been probably
probably probably not yeah weren't that
many people there oh shout out Avery he
found the moment in the live stream it
was in reference to Bruce okay cuz I I
need to see this I have no idea how yep
you we have a full list of all the
members from right now and
back what it's it
t you know what I'm saying you sound
like a Cy Master qu thank you we we
speak our our children go I see like
Bruce goes I see he doesn't say Daddy he
says Day Day a it's like one word day D
Day I see so I say sit that's it sit
sit
sit that's confusing definitely without
the explanation
mhm very
good very very good someone in the chat
said ace family steals credit cards
Ethan gives his credit cards away that's
the ag3 podcast difference right there
couldn't have said I mean be that's a
poetic shout out you can't say it any
better than that
all right here's what I want to do next
um here there's a couple more little
things here here's Dan running like an
NPC this was pretty
good let me full screen it like one day
you're saying well not but
like in like one day you're saying well
not but like what do you have to say for
yourself one day you're say I mean it's
not that weird is it you're jogging
yeah like you just saw a dragon it's
funny yeah I feel like if people could
see the floor they'd understand there's
a lot of wiring by right there yeah I'm
jumping over like three uh Cable
Crossovers right there true it's a fair
point he
makes
uh so okay here's what I I'm going to go
to the bathroom really fast okay and
then when I come back I want to
discuss uh something serious m
and real fast I don't want get too deep
into it I just have thoughts to share
about the Israel
thing um and then you guys can enjoy
this in the meantime somebody made this
fantastic me getting the ring
Dinger which I think oh my God it's the
back waxing
superimposed but it looks so good
doesn't it oh oh my
God crazy good really really
good
yeah really really impressive shout out
to uh a little
M we love that for you we love it about
all right I'll be right back guys one
moment sounds good meantime let me uh
try and catch up on some of these chats
o I'll be back love this Jazz this
needle drop that just uh put out here
it's pretty nice oh my God I'm trying to
scroll through Friday but there's so
many here we go all right uh peace and
love my friend made me a Teddy fresh
cake for my birthday I sent Dan a
picture in Discord oh let me go look for
that uh I'd love if you saw them I'm
looking I'm
[Music]
looking I don't see
it damn I don't good why are you telling
lies well uh resend it to me uh Carrie
was it worth all the
LIE uh I bet money she's still driving
that car oh Catherine could be be pretty
easy to figure out why does Ethan look
like it's CW Lex Luthor Mini
[Laughter]
Me CW Lex Luther is that the Smallville
one I believe so is CW Lex Luther did
anybody watch that show back in the day
I I did you did yeah I did oh wait maybe
they mean this one this isn't from
Smallville oh the John crier
small from the arrow verse
oh dude who watches these remember that
show Kyle XY he had like no belly button
yeah that's all I
had he just had no belly button I just
remember the commercials for it being
pretty funny that was the tagline the
man with no belly button wait no oh that
wasn't
pretty that's his super power just he no
Kyle XY the man with no belly button
that was just like no shot that was the
act the promo is just him like yeah yeah
yeah just his abs and it's just no belly
button
damn wow I haven't thought of this in so
long oh my God no you don't like that I
hate what I'm looking at why is that so
disturbing to not have a belly button
it's weird huhan Valley throws you off
yeah don't like it look it was a big
human or cake that's cake he's made of
cake interesting interesting yeah I um I
never call it Kyle XY any Kyle XY fans
shout out the CW shout out
CW let's
see uh getting caught up here people
saying they did watch that show really
Kyle XY Matt Dallas for the win is that
Matt Dallas Matt Dam it yeah
okay man with well shout out shout out
to all the Kyle XY shout out to Kyle XY
dude rip to the goat is he gone all
right I don't know you don't know okay
who's that it's Kyle XY dude Kyle XY the
man with no belly button do you remember
the show no the man with no CW where's
his belly button it's just he doesn't
have one dude that's what the whole show
is about he just has no belly button
yeah does he have powers no his pow is
that he doesn't have a belly button he's
like an alien thing oh really spoiler
alert oh I thought he was a clone
or something I could be I I I I just
know the promo but you're a human being
clearly you were incubated somewhere
like you're going to have a belly button
mhm unless it's just a genetic mutation
if you're uh but then you couldn't have
been
born you would have not been a viable
we're going to have to order the
complete first season to find out get it
now we're going to what a hook wow I'm
sold where's your belly button brother
bro what are you doing I don't think
anyone's talked about Kyle XY this much
in the past like uh 20 years ever he's
got abs I'll tell you that yeah just
looks weird wow
w
[Music]
surgery all kinds of stuff I'm Googling
it born without a belly button yeah it's
like a genetical anomaly surgery when
born how are you born without a belly
button how do you the just didn't have
an umbilical cord yeah probably isn't B
get yeah right I don't know I guess
Google Don't Lie guys
go I'm going to need more info about
that a lot more even even remember
there's like an actor that doesn't
actually have a bell but or something I
I feel like I remember
it people his name is Kyle XY people
born without a belly button I mean it
doesn't make sense it's like being born
without a strange but true bab's born
with no belly butt I'm reading about it
right now out of the baby girl according
to Centers for Disease Control and
prevention um researchers estimate that
about one in every 4,200 babies is born
with in the United States say it
again yeah I'm looking at that word
too okay so what does that
mean in the united many babies born with
anoel also have other I think that just
means s's belly button is attached to
the baby internally not externally
around the 11th week the abdominal wall
should seal off the intestines leaving
just a small hole for the umbilical cord
but wait this is what normally happens
so when it occurs this process doesn't
happen the way it's supposed to in
contrast the abdominal organs May
protrude in addition to the intestines
and whatever is protruding is encased in
aligning so the
umbilical internal guys at one point I
think the button was hit the audio
button what right now just right
now I went back and I I heard the I
heard the button sound wasn't me did you
accidentally tap I've been anywhere near
that button not me don't look at me uh
oh also chat GPT says you can't be born
without one he's lying no chat GP lying
he's lying but hold on I need a clear
explanation then how is this baby
born uh imagine it says imagine a piece
of cloth with a big hole in it yeah and
then imagine putting a sock through the
hole okay that sock is the lining and
the intestines and other organs are
inside the the uh sock doctors repair it
surgically or in some cases using a
technique called painting in which the
lining is drying off dried
off uh allowing the skin to grow over it
they're removing the belly button that
sounds I guess right not born without a
belly button like this freak well no one
is born with a belly Boton they're born
with
AAL and it's like the scar that forms a
scar so if for some reason it oh so
we're going we're going to do semantics
about the belly button thing also what
is a belly
button well any just imagine a birth of
defect and there's going to be a I don't
how well what if it's like it's not like
if you can dream it it's happened kind
of though but how there's like billions
and billions of people that's like you
can't like being born without a brain I
mean I don't think it's it can I mean
you know what I mean it's just I don't
understand how listen I'm not saying
it's impossible I just don't understand
the logistics of it you know okay here's
a picture that I don't know we probably
shouldn't show this a little graphic but
this will give you idea the baby comes
out looking like this oh they have a
mega belly button right but then there's
a surgery that can be done to correct it
and then it just looks flat like they're
okay so but they are okay I see yeah so
they still get their nutrients from
their umbilical this man is a fraud is
my point the guy that show cuz there
would be something there right you
cannot be born without the belly button
so who are you really and where did you
come from and what doctor did you go to
because your your belly button looks
super super smooth right looks
incredible who's your surgeon who's your
surgeon Dr James wiener wow Dr can do
all Kyle XY what is he ready for
spoiler what I don't know I'm just I'm
going to spoil it for myself what he is
what is he I don't feel like watching
the show oh yeah tell me I watch uh
species is listed as human on the uh
Kyle XY fandom Wiki uh so yikes
to those of you saying uh he's an alien
it's human
human well just go to the finale let's
read the synopsis of the finale okay
we're so invested in this Bringing Down
the House here we go the 10th and final
episode of the third season it's the
43rd episode overall just read the
synopsis so Kyle learns that lck is
already in production of a 100 clones of
himself okay so he's a clone he's a
clone I the Clone still needs the belly
button guys you know if we're going to
make a Sci-Fi show can we at least try
to keep it who is upkeeping the Kyle XY
fandom Wiki because the
plot empty to be added T go ahead Dan
add one right now let's let's clean it
up here I have this to say I have this
to say about the plot Kyle finds
out that it's impossible to be born
without a belly
button
right C funds out it's important boss
would be born without a belly button
which causes him to question am I a
clone am I an
alien am I really even
alive
[Music]
further and then you say further
according to chat
GPT it is not possible for a human baby
to be born without a belly
button
every human being has a belly button as
a result of their development and
birth it's not something that can be
absent in a natural healthy birth oh
well so that part cuz he's not natural
he's Supernatural so just say it's not
something that can be absent in
birth that can happen in birth in birth
yeah that's fine that's worded weird but
okay okay got it anything else you'd
like to have that's it
does it save it for real yeah yeah
bro we're in the
fandom we are in the
fandom wait read the whole synopsis it's
only a paragraph I'm curious now uh to
his horror Kyle learns that lck is
already in production of 100 clones of
himself to be kept similarly in tanks
for years Kyle and Jesse must find a way
to put a stop to it but they need all
the help they can get Josh has a small
part Jesse must stay out of sight so
Amanda had to help with the had
has to help her help the plan and Mark
gets dragged into it too oh not mark it
seems to go well until Nate and Cassidy
each make a sudden appearance story's
left hanging on more than one Cliff No
never got we didn't get the resolution
no where's the film where's the
follow-up
film and it's been since
2009 he has no belly but the boy without
a belly button all right thank you where
are we what are we
doing
um oh yeah there's something I want to
talk about I keep getting sidetracked
but I'm not super familiar with
Misfits they're like a a group a
video group they I know they had a
pretty um it's like popular podcast a
podcast I don't know much about them
either yeah and so love would know right
with him yeah so all these um
institutions are falling you
guys uh podcast Misfits apparently this
whole thing is in
shambles
um they're
ay
and I remember a few years ago they were
they were a big deal I remember they had
pokem man on it it had like
million million plus views wait did I
just see a Tedd fresh Beanie where
scroll up Scroll up Scroll up up up up
up one more row oh my God on the right I
think you're right oh that one too
greetings greetings greetings GRE please
don't be the please don't be the guy
who's the pedal who or not the pedal but
like the essay guy who's the guy with
the beanie greetings greetings that's
that's not Ryan is it please God don't
be Ryan where in the
[Music]
be please
is anyone able to fact check that chat
would chat knows well I what's the name
of the
person is Ryan P yeah I mean is this it
looks like it could be him is this the
same guy no no no that's not the same
guy it's not no don't no no no no this
is a good guy someone in that beanie
would never do what Ryan P did okay
right chat that's not the same guy and
apologies apologies to you my
friend
I love this guy can we make sure it's
not Ryan
p i i nobody in chat is willing to I
don't know who any of these people are
so all right Ryan P Misfits it doesn't
look like him here let's let's just
people are saying that's Toby that's
Toby I love Toby I Toby it's not Ryan
okay there you go exactly we love
Toby so this is their manager I guess
and um boy I don't know what's wrong
with
people
like he manages a podcast man and then
he's not even that serious and
then he's just basically taking
advantage of of uh young
boys I don't know the age I think they
were all age of consent but they were
basically coerced so and it sounds like
somewhere outright assaulted by
him
um
pretty intense stuff man the the
institutions they're
falling damn but here we are in the face
it's it's an institution this is what
I'm saying guys I just I draw this to
your attention to once again just
appreciate that we as an
institution are not built on one big
steel beam that could be melted by
jet fuel jet fuel we have multiple uh
loadbearing walls beams right right so
it take a lot more than
a airplane hitting us to take this show
down the are you talking about I
understand the analogy I was just doing
a world trade because uh yeah no I get
it it's just okay sure it's not a good
it wasn't that good yeah but I I thought
maybe I thought some of you guys knew
them cuz they pretty big but I I I'm
also not familiar I just saw somebody
post uh something that happened to them
by this guy Ryan P on on Twitter and it
was really really sad felt really bad
for this poor kid you
know I used to watch both uh Fitz and
Swagger Souls back in the days but and
then wasn't there a big drama around
this guy Fitz too yeah with um with call
me Carson and some girl that I don't
remember the name of sheet that on he
like took his girlfriend or something
yeah yeah it was this whole goly
man I just think like how do you is it
possible to get like six dudes together
that just one of them isn't like a
predator no no no no only I mean like
what's the odds we've never seen it
happen you get you just you know what I
mean you give them some mics and you say
oh you're doing a pcast now and then all
of a sudden they think they're Harvey
Weinstein sadly it's literally also the
boys off the
mic H it's just this is just what happen
boys podcast is that killer Keem why is
his head so why does it look
photoshopped why is his head so weird
they must have done something there's no
way but he was there I think yeah
probably some point but that being said
whose homie's name that I love Toby
Kobe's the man Toby Toby to Toto Toby
yeah Toto Toby yeah R Kobe though yes
but we love Toby awesome dude
man love him Reach Out Toby we love
you um so that's that I don't know I
don't know what to say but if memory
serves me the keemstar puffer fish
soundbite comes from his podcast
interview hold on let's
seear podcast hold on this is the
episode everybody's asking how many guys
are on our crew yeah what are you to say
I think and we're we're we defy we're
defying that's right the odds we're out
here you know that's what makes us so
special with our dicks in
pants and ladies firmly
in
um I don't know if ladies
really pose such a menace to society as
well we did just spend uh like two
months talking about Colleen Ballinger
right there there is that
aspect um but here it is the
500,000 hello and welcome back to the
misfitz podcast rated five stars on
iTunes by Bobby BL he says this podcast
is really good for sleep you just put it
on close your eyes and drift into
traffic oh c on the
time say what cam found the time stamp
it's at 356 how'd you find that already
I got my ways
3:56 puffer fish L some guy was like two
two kids in front of you like hey can I
punch my friend in this stomach for you
and he was just like yeah sure and then
I some guy just socked his friend in the
stomach and then they shook hands and
left what the so it's it was quite
the experience I don't think this ever
happened at one of our meetups but not
too bad nothing like Bond now I'm on the
edge of my seat how does keemstar
transition to puffer fish from
that I'm wondering that myself were you
sure this is the right time stamp it's
not 356 but yeah it's a 3 it's 10
seconds away I linked it there right
there if you want to click it
[Music]
fishing which was I know would you call
that a successful trip I dude I think so
I had a had a good time we had fun I
it's pretty strange right so in America
right you go into the pet store right
and you see all the fish right and
there's this like the the puffer fish
right there's there's no puffer fish in
pet stores that's not a thing is it well
in like a exotic fish store there would
be maybe in Buffalo I never seen a
puffer maybe not
whatever I've seen puffer fish really
you could buy a puffer fish I've never
seen one of those in you should get how
you got to get into fish bro yeah get
into fish oh yeah I'm seeing Petco fish
there you go I got a question Zach why
did you think to pull that Tim stamp
it's so because it's so out of pocket
and so random would come useful
and it did how' you even find it though
I don't even remember dude were
you watching this podcast I must have
been combing for keemstar
just cuz I have so many sound
from him yeah I must and it was so
Random I'm like how could I not have
that yeah just the puffer fish it turns
into a
circle the one that turns into a circle
right and like people people buy those
is funny man true shout out Zach thank
you for the visual thank you for the
gifted what a find the puffer fish right
the one that's turns into a circle he
holds up a circle um back when I worked
at Adult Swim they had a show that was
called fish Center Live and they had two
puffer fish fish in the fish tank there
you go so that's how I knew you can get
puffer fish you can get puffer anywhere
dude yeah can we get a puffer fish here
let's get a fish sure I didn't know that
was a thing we'll get puff fish you know
will it turn into a circle all right so
here's what I want to talk about oh
ela's ready so we'll do this thing
then obviously everybody's heard about
what's happening in Israel do you want
me to let her in now yeah you can let
her in okay so uh um you know oh hey I'm
just I just started talking about it
right the one that turns into a
circle I see her behind a little bit I
see the
delay can you hear me hey yes okay yeah
I was just starting to talk about
it okay so
over it's a delay so I didn't
realize so over the
weekend Hamas who is the governing uh I
mean they're terrorist organization but
they're
also control Gaza
Strip they
um somehow managed to put together
this surprise
invasion of uh into
Israel
um and it was you know it was horrific
there
was so far at least 700 is
died which is nuts one of the one of the
crazy things was there was a a nature
party a peace party they actually call
it
ironically and I guarantee a lot of
people there were
were
um pro
peace you know who are anti uh Netanyahu
and all that kind of stuff and so yeah
for sure they were all young um
definitely that type of crowd that is
unhappy with the
government and so
260 people
got violently brutally murdered by
terrorists and the the the really sad
kind of crazy thing is that I don't know
if this has changed but last that I
heard Hamas didn't even know about the
party they just happened upon
it that's that uh
and so um but that was 260 they were
also invading lots of villages and Kuts
and
towns and uh just going you know build
door too and just
murdering families kidnapping Children
Killing Children
kidnapping desecrating people's bodies I
mean just the most horrific acts of
Terror that you can imagine on a an
insanely uh on an Ane scale
too one of the crazy Parts was or Ela
was watching Israeli news when it first
started happening because the I don't
think American News had really caught up
yet but there was people calling in from
like their safe room or their houses or
from hiding being like
Whispering yeah it was so hard and like
I've been watching the news nonstop
since it started and that on that day it
started at 6:00 a.m. Saturday
and the whole day um people were calling
the news because they called police they
called everybody and nobody was coming
to help them for hours until like late
that day um which was too late for for
most of them and yeah some I heard awful
calls like moms with their
children whispering in their safe room
like I I can hear them outside I hear
gunshots everywhere please send somebody
please send somebody oh yeah and then so
families would be locked in the safe
rooms and then the terrce would light
the house on fire
M yeah so some yeah some they just light
on fire um some they ended up getting to
some they kidnapped and you see stories
of
um like there there's one guy who found
out through a video on
socials that his wife and two young
children and mother motherin-law were
all taken
hostages um the mom and the children
went to visit the
mother-in-law and he wasn't with them
and he ended up seeing the video of them
being taken away on socials and then
he's calling the news on that day and
he's telling them I just saw this and
nobody's calling me nobody's telling me
anything and that's still until now all
the families that have people taken from
them they have nobody calling them like
no officials there's no no lines of
support for them nothing I think the
government is so overwhelmed because
this was such a surprise for everybody
um it's just like horrific stories one
after the
other and most of this has just been
like people the citizens themselves
creating support groups people are
cooking now and sending other people
food there's all kinds of stuff
happening they're just like people
trying to help people right now
so the part
that I I dude I had a hard time being
online because first of all this always
happens in conflicts like this but every
there's so many fake videos and
stuff people post but then the the other
thing that's been really hard is
seeing you know what let me do this
before I even talk about this let me
just tell you first of
all just so it's not n ambiguous about
how I feel about this situation as a
whole okay let me just say
this disgusting weirdos um I
tweeted this I I think this was when um
the IDF blew up some apartment building
or some horrific in Gaza a
few years
ago I said the Israeli government is
making me sick even if Hamas is
operating as civilian buildings it
doesn't justify the total Destruction of
that building it's inhumane netan is a
piece of warmonger needs to go as a
dual citizen I love Israel and the
Israeli people they deserve a government
that actually believes in peace and not
force in violence the ultra right Jewish
settlers among the greatest provocators
in the world they are Shameless hateful
fueled by religious Zeal and enabled by
the Israeli government I wish the
settling and reposition of Palestinian
land would stop I wish the bombing in
Gaza would stop gaza's desert to live a
life free of fear for all the crimes
Hamas has committed we must always
remember that they are not Palestine the
Israeli government holds holds all the
power and is on them to stop Devol and
show a true willingness for peace okay
so just so it's not unambiguous and also
if you need further
proof I was honored by this Twitter
poster do we not have the original
one can you find the original one she uh
I don't know how how big this went PSA
for those new to the is Palestine fandom
which is a really
she's being cynical I think
right um here's an important refresher I
made it to the celebrities who support
Palestine and
um and um very
flattering actually a lot of the
comments were like is that Ethan picture
real yes it's from a while ago she
said um
there was uh oh there's more
here no that's not real he Photoshopped
it because um the main insult that
Andrew Tate types with theirm is he's
being fat and then she responded
literally has it on his on his pfp
pretty sure it's
him so there we go which I like the top
comment in our thread on Reddit uh
especially when their picture is their
profile picture is of Olivia wild and we
can plainly just assume that they are
not Olivia wild in this current
moment I guess maybe I should update it
I don't know when I saw that I was like
I maybe I should update my
profile pick maybe it's time maybe it's
time it must have been deleted I'm not
seeing it oh okay I found the this post
was deleted by the post author and I
found like all of the comments
underneath where she's like yes it's
from a while ago and then someone's like
no it's not real they realized that it
was wrong literally has it on their
profile photo pretty sure it's him wait
how do we know for certain though maybe
he said it because deep down it is him
to my podcast do five episodes a week
damn let go click something anyway
whatever I don't care it was funny yeah
but the point
is before anyone thinks otherwise let me
just get that out of the way now the
thing the thing that I've been seeing
online that makes me uh
sick is
that just like brazen
uh enthusiastic support for
Hamas um like this so there was even
before Israeli responded at all like the
first 12 hours was just wanting Massacre
of civilians kidnapping desecrating of
bodies just absolute uh terrible
unjustifiable uh violence and
terrorism
and immediately I see so many left
leftists being like um I stand with
Palestine which I do stand with
Palestine right but if there's so if
there's a unpro if there's not
unprovoked but if there's a terrorist
attack where 700 people are killed and
your immediate response is I stand with
Palestine what am I how am I supposed to
interpret that other than I stand with
Hamas is Israel hasn't done anything
they haven't air stried Gaza all that's
happening is that they're trying to
count dead
bodies but that I mean that's not the
most gruesome takes but I've seen a lot
of that and it's like um it's a ma am I
am I missing something there I don't see
any other way to interpret like I stand
with Palestine first of all an insult to
Palestinians there's 2 million people
there and I guarantee you a lot of them
aren't terrorists or four
terrorist ISM so you know what I mean
that I don't think that represents the
people of Palestine and does anyone a
favor just seems to me like they're
cheering on
terrorists um am I missing something
like I don't know how else I'm supposed
to interpret that the only thing that
they're they're saying I agree with is
that 700 people were murdered in Cold
Blood burned alive desecrated I don't
get it it's disgusting it's actually
really horrific I've seen it so much uh
that's not just saying you're Pro
Palestine wasn't the worst stuff I've
seen though I don't want to call anybody
out because I don't want to get into it
honestly but I've seen a few prominent
lefties I'm sure you'll see you've seen
them all that are just
like they can't they don't care
they just don't care it's really sad
it's like really
sad it's like America and Iraq we killed
a fuckload of people there horrific so
imagine a group of terrorists Iraqi
terrorists made it into
La went to a neighborhood and just
started killing everybody going in the
houses dragging them out burning them
alive kidnapping kids desecrating
people's
bodies who's going to go I stand with
the people of Iraq right after that
happens that's
psychotic I just saw a Survivor from the
party from the rave party talking about
his experience and it's just it's
horrific it's hard to I think it's hard
to explain to people what people just
went
through um but he saw all of his friends
die in front of him they were all trying
to hide and a terrorist came and just
shot all of them point blank in the face
looking at them and smiling and then
dragging buddies and dancing and playing
music it's just that's not that's just
barbaric that's just
disgusting it's just the people's like
hesit their hate for Israel is like
preventing people
from it's like they're supporting Hamas
terrorism and you see all kinds of takes
like like on one hand I understand
understand that there's
not let me pull this up choose my words
carefully
here you know the other thing is
that there's another misconception that
these people who are being killed are
settlers there are no settlements around
Gaza these are just normal ass towns
these are normal people living normal
lives in their little communities the
settl are in the West Bank every
settlement around Gaza was was evacuated
in 2005 forcibly by the government those
normal people of very different
political leaning like some were
probably left leaning and some were
probably right just like here how you
have conservative and you have Democrat
a lot of people in Israel are not happy
with the government there's there's been
so many protests in the last year the
whole country practically has been
protesting and so so it's not like
everybody that died is a settler that
the settlers are like the craziest of
Israel so people make a what I think is
a decent point they say settlers aren't
civilians they're you know inserting
themselves into this uh violent
clash and I I agree with that to an
extent I understand and so people who
are desperate to um defend
Hamas uh um are saying that these people
were settlers they were not settlers
there's no settlements around Gaza these
were just normal people
children family
kids and
um it's really disturbing frankly the
amount of people that I've seen just
like are like let's go let's
go I stand with palisin right after a
terrorist attack am I crazy that that I
know what that
means I stand with Palestine too but if
right after the world the the planes hit
the World Trade Center you saying
something
like I don't even know what to say I
stand with Al Qaeda I mean what the
I guess that's not the same I think my
analogy of
Iraqis invading La is good we
did so much wrong
to the Iraqi people and the country
nobody saying would even disagree with
that at this point and a lot of the same
stuff I'm seeing people say about
Palestine you could
say what are the Iraqis supposed to do
they don't have any
recourse um this is the only way they
can express
themselves
um you know what I mean like they uh
they they have every right oh I've SE
seen this stuff too um they're calling
it self-defense they
go
uh libs are like so excited
for Palestinian rights and for the
apartheid to end but when they do
something about it then everyone pauses
like they're doing something about it is
murdering 700 civilians in just the most
horrific way possible and so if you
imagine that a thousand Iraqis somehow
invaded la as uh you
know as revenge for the awful things the
American government did
there right so we could look at that and
say sure in a sense I I get it right and
you could say like oh America deserves
it whatever like in the sense of justice
like I understand that concept that
you're getting at but when they go to a
block a neighborhood of people and just
again in the most violent disgusting inh
main barbaric way murdering kids
kidnapping kids desecrating bodies
burning people alive and then you're
going to go I stand with Iraq I mean
that that's
crazy you can stand with Iraq and also
condemn Hamas being monsters
which people don't want to do it's crazy
you know and Hamas they're not dude
they're not Freedom Fighters Hamas is
terrorist they terrorize the
people of of Gaza just as just as much
you know what I mean mean they're just
like a a
fundamental extremist terrorist
group you know they also terrorize the
Palestinians that that are under their
rule it's crazy dude it's crazy
man it's really nauseating to see some
of the people
uh you know just ignoring that it's
crazy it's crazy and again I'm not and
now it's I can look at it and
say that you know Ethan you're being
intentionally Cho shut the
up people are saying Israel does that on
the daily the idea that onily that's not
what I'm talking about see that's what
you're doing you're excuse you're you're
excusing people being burned alive and
kids being murdered you're saying
Israeli Israel does that on the daily
okay now I'm not denying that I'm not
deny
so are you so are you in favor of an
Iraqi uh terrorist cell coming to kill
everyone in your neighborhood are you
willing to sacrifice your life to an
Iraqi terrorist for what we did in in
Iraq go ahead you know I don't see the
difference I don't I mean America
killed a million Iraqis by some
estimates that's a hell of a lot more
than Palestinians who have died at the
hands of
Israel
so so let's let's bring an Iraqi
terrorist group to your neighborhood and
you just go out and be slaughtered and
your mom be slaughtered and your kids be
slaughtered and you burned alive
barbaric it's horrific and again
I'm saying that I support Palestine
there's no other way for me to
uh I don't know how more I can express
that you
know some somebody here's an an Israeli
because it shekles they say Palestinians
voted homas into power in 2006 Ethan
they represent the Palestinian
people dude I don't think the
Palestinians
understood the scope of what Hamas who
they are and I don't think there's been
free election since that happened it's
been yeah in 2006 was a long
time ago Hamas they took power and they
stayed in power they're violent
terrorists and I don't think it's fair
to say that
represents Palestinians there's 2
million people there they're not all
terrorists
okay um Gaza is an open air prison okay
I agree but I agree that's what I'm
saying you know what I mean so go
sacrifice your family to Iraqi
terrorists if you care about Freedom so
much like there's just a callousness
that I've seen online and support for
just violent terrorists that's
been
nauseating
you
know standing with
Palestine oh there's so many comments
Ethan please learn more about this shut
the up you're clearly taking a side
here you loser you I think Ethan has a
lot of credibility to talk about it he
lived there for five years and he's
married to an Israeli I know you care
about find to like sit in America and
think that you're know better than
somebody who lives in Israel go please
go let's go bring the Iraqi terrorist to
your to your block to murder your whole
family and then talk about how it's
Justified um if you care about Palestine
the way you're framing it is a really
bad take what that burning
family's alive is is should be uh
condemned is that a bad take then you
need to see a
doctor if that's a bad take you need to
see a doctor
okay like I can't emphasize how much
Israel has
um
suppressed destroyed ruined
palest Palestinians
lives the worst thing that's so hard to
to Def impossible to defend is the um
the settlements that our government sh
sanctioned in the in the West Bank it's
horrific and it's it is an act of war
and an act of you know cultural
genocide and it's and it's
horrific
okay right and the government of Israel
is a colossal failure bet Netanyahu is a
war criminal a psycho I voted
against him every time I could and young
people don't want him in there
either I mean the whole country of they
hate him they hate the government they
literally have been protesting they've
been out on the streets like the whole
last year people there are so fed up
with the government in Israel they could
not feel any worse about it they they do
not feel the government represents them
at all oh here this is a good analogy
too let's say a group of Native and I'm
not saying that these are peaceful
people again I'm I'm only speaking
hypothetically let's say a group of
Native American terrorists come off of a
uh a reservation and come to your
neighborhood and start killing
everybody dude are you you going to be
like hey I I support okay I deserve it
come shoot me come rape me but listen
because I was born in this country just
come and rape me freely it's it's my
fault no if I was there I would fight
for my family and for my home because I
need a home to live my family needs a
home to live in right a basic right
everybody needs that and same for
Palestinians I'm not saying they don't
just like Ethan said I never voted for
baby in my life I never would people are
wishing death on these kots families
kids women they what's their only crime
is being born somewhere same as the
Palestinians frankly I mean obviously
it's way better off to be on the Israel
side but their crime is being born
somewhere they didn't choose to be born
in Israel they didn't choose to
be part of this uh political termoil and
they're not they weren't
settlers
so think about what they're saying when
immediately after a terrorist attack
people saying I support Palestine and
what they don't mean Palestine they mean
Hamas let's say the Native Americans
they come to your neighborhood and they
just start burning people alive killing
people kidnapping kids desecrating
bodies and the first take is you know I
support the Native American uh Revenge I
support Native
American uh militi
I support Native Americans it's like
what it's like yeah of course we I
support Native Americans too but like
did you not just see that they killed
700 people you
know
um somebody said I found a too oh maybe
I shouldn't read
that did catch my attention though and
it wasn't about
this um I'm only saying that from what I
saw there are people on Twitter
prominent lefties who are so
callous they feel nothing for these
dumbest analogy possible shut
the up what's Dumber what could be
it's right on how's it dumb the Iraqi
one the Native American one they're
pretty much right on it's War innocent
people die all right so let's bring the
Iraqis out iraqy terrorist group to your
neighborhood and see if you care if
people murder everyone you love burn
them alive
You're such cowards such losers
you're sitting here in America by the
way America who's who's probably
committed the most
atrocious crimes of Against Humanity of
any recent country and you're going to
sit here and be
like go
Hamas get a grip
dude it's literally Columbus Day that's
true that is an interesting
coincidence I'm sorry I don't see what's
possibly wrong with the analogy how how
is it
wrong how is it about analogy I think
what people don't understand when they
say that is like what it means to
somebody in Israel is going through
grieving right now of so many people
around them and their life as it used to
be that nobody knows right now what to
expect and how long this war is going to
last like when you come out and say free
Palestine after they just lost everybody
they have children taken away from them
that's not if you're really for
humanitarian reasons that's not what you
should be saying right now and we all
and I'm free Palestine too right it's
just the timing I know what it is you're
saying I support Hamas I mean that's
what you're that's what you're saying
maybe not even intentionally you know
but that is yeah it might not be
intentionally but that that is what it
means and that their mission was to kill
all Jewish people 700 people
were murdered
dude kids man they're killing kids
dude kidnapping children burning them
alive and y'all are like let's go Hamas
not y'all but like the left there's some
liberals they're just they don't
care man they don't care and it's crazy
to me it's crazy you know in the same
sense it's like we all want peace and
I'm readily admit all the everything
that the government of Israel has
done to instigate this right and like I
I also can look at it and admit that the
terrorist attack is a consequences of
Israel's occupation I see that and I
understand what you're
saying that being
said I'm pretty sure that you need to
slaughter 700 civilians and uh to uh
that number is going to go up by the way
there's 2,000 injured still besides that
700 and a lot of them are in a bad
condition yeah and again it's like the
people that they're killing are probably
the majority of them are are uh you know
free Palestine too Palestinian children
are dying right now too right
yeah it's horrible yeah and I wouldn't
I'm not saying go Israel when they when
is go celebrate that I wouldn't put on
music and start dancing to that I
wouldn't if when Israel attacks a
blows up like a residential
building I don't go to Twitter and say I
stand with Israel I mean some people do
right and that's barbaric too that's
psychotic you know but I don't I don't
do that and there's a if y'all really
want peace it just makes me wonder like
do you really think that cheering on
mosque killing 700 people and to be
going up is like the
Israeli military and even the people of
Israel now are being galvanized to go on
a fullscale invasion of Gaza
like the result of this is going to be
so horrific and I and I feel for the
people of Gaza I feel so bad for them
and what they're gonna what's going to
happen to them and you know Netanyahu is
a he goes people in Gaza
get out now cuz we're going to level it
it's like get out where dumbass it's
like it's like a joke that he says that
and he's a bloodthirsty lunatic
but like the result of this is going to
be I I I I uh I'm scared to even imagine
the the casualties that going to happen
as a result of this in
Gaza um and
so that's that's all I'm saying I mean
this this was terrorist attack
doesn't seem hard to be like it's yeah
I'm sorry that happened it's sad I don't
support Hamas you know I just don't see
that being that hard seems pretty
uncontroversial to just not support
Hamas and a radical terrorist
organization it's
crazy doesn't seem that
hard you guys stop chat h no
no I've seen people that I like and that
I followed doing
like it's been really hard to see doing
just straight
up just straight up Hamas propaganda
man you
know like
what I don't even want to say it dude I
don't want to get into it with people
it's too
up me you don't have to say who but like
what what is being said that's upsetting
all right you tell me if you think this
you don't want to you tell me if you
think this is up hold on okay let
me pull this
up the reason I asked is just because
you you yourself saying that you know
you have a lot of sympathy for
Palestinians and understand the free
Palestine movement and everything and I
just wonder are people explicitly saying
that they like Kamas or are you
you how would you interp okay here let
me show you this and then you tell me
what you think hold on I'm find trying
to find this
post I'm just
scrolling so much
hold
on did you send something no I'm I'm
scrolling
still
um
go ahead hold
music ah God so many
posts something I would chime in with um
you know obviously I'm not from there um
I do have family member who lives in
Israel he's lived there since the 60s
and so I was speaking to him over the
week weekend and I was very curious
because you know obviously he's older
and um like you were saying Ethan that
the uh most of the young people are not
fans of uh the right-wing government
that is in control of Israel right
now um but I didn't know I didn't know
uh what his opinions would really be
like so I asked him and um and I was
relieved to hear that he hates Netanyahu
and uh has been against him for a long
time um and I guess I'm just bringing up
that point
to show that it isn't even just like a
young generational thing I mean there
are a lot of uh older Boomer age people
as well that um here's here's Mia here's
Mia Khalifa okay it this picture is
from a video of them in trucks just
indiscriminately killing people they're
going through a village and they're just
murdering people there's a video of it
and she tweets it out and said this is a
Renaissance
painting this is a Renaissance painting
that's what she
said it's a weird thing to
say that dude it's psychotic
that dude it's up a murder
scene terrist you're just a you're just
Pro terrorism I'm sorry that's that's
horeshit it's disgusting and
like again I support Palestine as much
as any body does you know and by the way
Iron alert Hamas would love you Mia go
go and
list I see what you're saying by the way
I see a lot of people asking so my my
family is okay um they're safe it's just
it's really scary my mom is like scared
she can't cuz she's by herself so she
doesn't want to be alone right now so
she's staying with
family everybody terrified and every
time I call her she's
crying I have friends that know somebody
that is missing that went to the
party and it's really scary yeah um I
mean your best friend's husband got
called into the
reserves her one of her friends is
missing you know Israel is a small
country it affect
everybody and
so
I just the the callousness towards
civilians being slaughtered I'm not even
talking about Israelis I'm not talking
about Palestinians just a callousness
towards the slaughter of innocent
people I'll try to find another one
it while I'm
here
um hold
on let me
see
thank you
[Music]
Zach you
do now but then like also I'll say this
there's really psychotic takes on the
right which is more like about how you
know making crazy sweeping
generalizations about Palestinians being
all terrorists and which is you
know equally insane
uh
equally up and
horrific
um uh maybe he unliked it hold
on here okay here here here I'm going to
send this I'm curious what you found uh
Olivia
send
to we're not going to talk about this
whole episode I'm just I'm just saying
something about something that's
important and then we'll move
on so this girl you can pull that
up now
this
go
ahead you got I sent it in the WhatsApp
oh you sent in WhatsApp
sorry so this tweet was liked by Matt
Lech who's a he works for with Sam Cedar
at the majority report MH I respect him
and what they do
there
and yet this crazy Hamas apologist
propaganda he's liking it this girl
there's a video of her being
kidnapped I think this happened at the
nature party where she just witnessed
300 people some OD being absolutely
slaughtered in Cold Blood so look at
this scroll up so this this
propagandist liar says she wasn't
murdered awarded or abused footage shows
her moments later safe in
Gaza so here she is with a bottle of
water after the same people just
murdered 300 people in Cold Blood
murdered them right in front of
her you know how is this proof I don't
even know if this picture was taken
before it may have been even taken
before she was
captured but how is
this proof that H like Hamas is some
kind of humanitarian they're they're
going to take good care of her they just
killed 300 of her friends in front of
her what are you talking about don't you
see that this is like Hamas whitewashing
propaganda am I wrong it's
insane it's like she's fine you
guys you know and this girl by the way
her
dad has been going on the media talking
about how he supports two states and
wants peace and you know what I and is
against the violence even you know even
after his daughter who I'm sure has the
same exact Politics as him was
kidnapped and all of her friends killed
in front of her and that's her husband
by the way who's being uh taken at
gunpoint probably murdered and by the
way Hamas says they're going to start
murdering civilians one at a time on
TV so I'm sure they're going to take
really good care of her like Hamas is
some kind of humanitarians to follow
like Rules of Engagement it's just I
don't know to me am I wrong I mean
that's up it's like why are you
liking that all it's doing is just white
washing
Hamas she's
fine it's
crazy yeah they dragged her away her
boyfriend's missing he was dragged away
right in front of her she was was she
paraded around dead no I don't I don't
think that was her but there was another
girl who's body was just basically
people were celebrating and dancing
around her corpse and just dragging
it I'm not I'm not celebrating that I'm
not celebrating any like
that and so
like oh yeah this was another weird
story 23 and me got hacked and people
specifically obtained ashkanazi Jew data
did you see that story we talked about
it on Friday I think you were maybe
black drunk at the time that's why I
remember they're uh they're going to
come right to my doorstep dude Crystal
knocked that's weird yeah that that's
terrifying yeah and Israel said they're
leveling Gaza yeah and so when the
did and I've been saying that that's
psychotic
too so but so then because the
government of Israel is psychotic
barbaric freaks okay then you're going
to be like
Hamas you going say then it's then it's
cool what's Hamas is doing what's the
point of saying that saying yeah Israel
does bad stuff too right so what is the
point of saying that you're trying to
justify Hamas killing people sorry I
don't support either one of
them you
know that's it man gross I think
people are way too comfortable just
being pro terrorists right now makes me
want to
puke
it's going to get worse before it gets
better a lot
worse it's going to get a lot
worse
man
sad dude are you even are you guys even
listening to what I'm saying I do not
support Hamas but it's wild to act like
Israel hasn't acted similarly for
decades bro are you listening to what
I'm
saying like are people even listen the
the words I'm
saying I don't know doesn't seem like
it I'm just saying don't cheer for
terrorists who parade around desecrated
corpse and kill children and burn
families alive I don't I don't think
that that's a crazy
take if you think it is then let's let's
go invite the Iraqi terrorist who are
exacting Revenge well-deserved Revenge
to come to your city block and kill
every one you love and burn them
alive cool
man they we deserve it right I mean do
we deserve Americans do we all deserve
to be burned
alive because of what our government has
done how much has the American
government done how bad do we all
deserve to die how many of you all are
keyboard Warriors sitting at
home in America okay and the safety of
your home you deserve to
die is that what you're saying
cuz I don't think you believe that I
don't think you'd be
cool who's cheering for them a lot of
people a
lot I don't need to talk about Israel
horrible things I've done that I've done
that I talk about the horrible things
Israel's done I've done that I do
that thank you
that's all I have to say so if you if
you think Hamas is dope just
remember that you more even more than
Israelis perhaps deserve to be uh burned
alive by terrorists and your whole
family murdered in front of you so there
you
go in fact why don't you just make it
easier why don't you just fly to
uh fly to uh Isis and do them a favor
and just let them you know just Serve
Yourself on a platter for them because
you deserve it
scumbags
freaks bloodthirsty Savage
freaks
man oh here's another Israeli one Ethan
Eli I know it's hard to present this
position to your audience who have
difficult time to accept it but that's
why your statement is very meaningful
people need to hear these things thank
you Assa and again I'm not even I'm not
even voicing the smallest support for
Israel I am again so opposed to the
Israeli government and I fully
acknowledge the cultural genocide the
stealing of land um and the provoc the
provoking and the creation of terrorism
are a result of Israel's actions I don't
doubt that at all in fact I mean that's
literally what's
happening and also Palestinians are not
Hamas so yall being like Hamas
does a massive terrorist attack and your
response is I support Palestine you're
not doing them any favors cuz guess what
they're not
terrorists to million of those people
are probably just peaceloving folks that
want to live not live in fear watch
their loved ones and homes being blown
up I Hamas is bringing hell on them too
right
now because you know that Israel is
going to react and that's not going to
be good for the innocent people over
there either it's going to be horrible
and there's going to be so many gods
and civilians that are going to die
because of Israel
because the Israel government is
barbaric genocidal
Freaks and I hate
them here come the black helicopters
I know I hear criticize Israel you
know what I mean how how what more do
you want me to say I'm just stopping
short of saying gu the chat probably
didn't hear it there was a helicopter
flying over the building really low just
now basically I agree with you up to
just coming close to saying uh normal
civilians deserve to be murder murdered
alive because of where they were born I
guess that's the only so if you if you
think that I'm missing the point then
you can go to Isis uh and let
them kill you for your the crimes of
your
country crazy
man I don't
know normalized
Terror yeah basically
Logan I mean Israel are doing terrorists
too they're
terrorists I mean on and they have all
the power Israel has all the power the
power and balance is crazy
right I want to show you something that
say Ethan they're
fascists I think that you is I'm listen
I'm not I'm not not saying that because
I I don't think that they're the people
in power there are fascists I just think
that that that label is used very
liberally and I don't think I even
really know what it means but what more
do you want me to say they're genocidal
murderous war criminals I mean
Jesus is that not
enough what
Dan I saw something that made me raise
an eye row this morning
um did you see news about this I don't
know so uh and ELO you can correct me if
I'm wrong but uh this is pronounced
shinb so it's basically like Israeli FBI
right I think so like police internal
police as opposed to most is
intelligence or or enforcement cuz if
it's intelligence more like CIA I guess
CIA is international though um that's
why I say FBI CU they are domestic
intelligence service anyways um when the
head of shinb the Israeli domestic
intelligence service warned Netanyahu
earlier this year that deadly attacks by
settlers on Palestinians would increase
the security threat to Israel he was
roundly denounced by members of
netanyahu's lud party one lud Member of
Parliament complained the ideology of
the left has reached the top echelons of
shined the Deep state has
sh is sorry Shin is basically shabbach I
think that's like the same thing it's
what shabbach it's like another way
Shak yeah what is shabak what is that oh
okay um it's like
the Defense Force
or yeah probably like Military
Intelligence or something yeah the key
part here is that when they warned that
um what all these escalations are going
to result in retaliation uh they
basically told them that they're woke
and uh and that they're the Deep State
dude n who needs to be like removed from
oist right now besides for the war
crimes the failure of the military to
like um intelligence apparatus to see
this coming is is staggering and you
know I saw that this morning too and I
saw that all he said is that he's
denying that that ever happened or that
he ever talked to them I don't know dude
he needs to be removed he needs
to be thrown in jail sick of that
guy and it's like the
terrorists I don't know what their
objective is exactly but I'll tell you
what's going to happen Netanyahu who was
so deeply unpopular is now going to gain
a whole new Salo of
support he's going to create a fullscale
invasion of
Gaza with tons of new people backing him
up as a result of this cuz it's like the
wartime you know that wartime thing yeah
exactly they're afraid U it's the
wartime thing everyone you know nobody
wants to remove their leader during a
war and so the only thing that's
happened is further
entrenching the C is further dividing
the chasm between of Peace that's
between Palestinians and
Israelis there couldn't be anything
worse for peace than this so I don't
know what you mean when you say I
support
Palestine after Hamas kills 700 people I
don't know what do you mean by that what
do you mean you support
Palestine do you
want like potentially a
100,000 I don't know how many are going
to die tens of thousands because that's
what's going to result from this do you
support I don't know what you mean you
support pal
and right after a terrorist
attack
um I don't I don't get it how I don't
understand what's the good thing what
possibly as good is going to come out of
this that they think is like
righteous I don't get it it's
crazy and it really it really is
up how these people they they promote
Hamas
terrorists as freedom for
Palestinians it's the most ironic thing
but they're not they're not pal they
don't represent the Palestinian people
they're terrorists and if
anything this is going to get us further
from the objective of Peace so much
further is not going towards peace no
and now there's like over a hundred
hostages they said this morning they're
going to start executing them live one
by one there's even American hostages
that are being held by by Hamas that's
going to be American citizens were
killed by Hamas uh during that and the
kidnapping of American citizens I don't
I'm not even sure how that's going to
play out in terms
of
policy but you
know I don't know it just doesn't seem
that uh controversial to say that I
don't support families being burned
alive and kids being murdered and
kidnapped sorry if that's not woke
enough apparently for
people that's basically all I wanted to
say Ethan can you actually point to
prominent leftist celebrating Hamas
violence I already did fre Palestinians
calling for an end of aparte in this
brutal cycle I understand
that talking about the timing of people
who right after a terrorist
attack
um whatever
stupid listen you can choose not to hear
what I'm saying or or you can hear what
I'm saying ultimately it's up to
you you don't support Palestine what the
how could you even type
that just stop looking at the chat yeah
I mean it it's remember that person was
not listening let's see like just listen
to everything I said that's it just
listen to what I
said it's possible that some people are
only joing now half
of dude I don't want to call people out
okay I don't want to do it if you
haven't seen what I've seen then good
then then there's no problem I guess in
your life I've seen it I've seen it a
lot and it's it's really uh made me sick
if you haven't seen it then I'm happy
I'm happy for you you know what I mean
then
good
great that's
it what is p what is this PSPs thing
people are
spamming uh it's probably a Palestinian
flag uh they don't render in the chat
properly okay I see the flag emoji so it
it just shows like a symbol usually I
see uh there it is thank you guys so
remember if um if I'm not woke enough
then I urge you to surrender yourself to
Isis to pay for the crimes of our
country please thank you so much thank
you please in fact you should probably
pay for them to come out and murder
everyone on your block because we
deserve it as
Americans
thanks your opinion is not the only
right one so what's the other opinion
that civili that it's okay to kill
civilians that's the other opinion next
to mine so I guess people yeah you're
right some people do believe that and
apparently you do too you sick
freak all right thanks anything else
Ela no it just it seems I don't know
there's also like it's a little hard
when there's so much anti-Semitism
online
too this is just kind of like
opening a way for them to to go wild so
it's kind of hard
to to see
sometimes who really means
what of course right but then you can't
even say that because people go oh
you're not the
victim like well in this case they were
the V there were victims actually there
were victims 700 of them plus and still
are and still still
happening
all right shout out to all my Pro
terrorist Americans out there we love
you
guys thank you so
much all right thank
you that's about it thanks Ela thank
you thanks thank you so
much thank you
thanks thank you so much all right
thanks for calling
in okay
then all right thanks for nice to see
you I'll see you later
okay all right thank you all right I'll
talk to you
later bye all right
bye okay she actually hung
up I mean this like you
you're it's
crazy it's crazy I know it's not about
anti-Semitism but her point
is there's a lot of anti-Semitism and
you know people jump at the opportunity
to but obviously it's not about
anti-Semitism about what Israel does to
Palestinians
so I understand her point
but it's not one that needs to be made
to talk about
it all right all right what else what
else is there to say anyone want to say
anything or nobody wants to touch
this got any Goofs and
gaffs in that dock of
yours I do I have a
lot um yeah I'm sure me and his will
have a conversation about it although I
don't think he's going to disagree with
what I'm saying otherwise he'd probably
be
a Hamas supporter cuz that's basically
all I'm
saying I'm I'm
saying let's not Slaughter
civilians and I doubt Hassan's going to
disagree with that that would be
surprising that would be surprising what
I've seen Hassan say is like the
terrorism is a result of Israel's
occupation which I agree with
right um apparently the Israeli
intelligence service agrees with that
take
so it'd be pretty hard to uh to disagree
at this stage yeah I mean it's it's just
obtuse to say I mean obviously um these
thing that's that is the root of
terrorism and and resistance is it is an
option of Last Resort and the hardliners
in Israel have largely driven people
to take violent action um as a means of
Last Resort and that doesn't mean mean
that it's right but we can understand it
and you know see it with open eyes
without um without having to embrace it
you know what I mean without having to
celebrate the slaughter of
Innocence that's it that's all I'm
trying to say you know but but the pro
the proof is I know chat isn't
representative but people are like oh
really well where is it it's the people
in chats calling me uh disgusting right
now
like they're there these are the people
I'm talking about because I just said
I'm seeing lots of people that are
insisting that them saying free Palin
does not mean that they support humas
and I agree and I mean you you said that
as well no no but what I was going to
say is anyone who's saying uh people
don't actually have that opinion I've
banned about six of them who say that no
it actually is great that they're
killing them and they should drive them
all out so like to pretend like people
don't have that opinion is you're you're
being purposely up to
and that's those are the only people if
you if you are one of those people that
are saying that you support the
Palestinians um but you don't
necessarily support Hamas slaughtering a
bunch of civilians then you have the
same take as Ethan and you need to take
a step back and realize
that the part that I don't understand is
I've seen people online with a take like
yours similar to yours and just getting
totally roasted for for any any morsel
of support for for the people of Israel
what they're going through yeah that's
what I find deeply disturbing with this
and that's it people go oh really well
name one person it's like everywhere all
the time if you don't see it great I
mean you know what I mean I I don't have
to prove it to you I'm just telling you
my experience just telling you what I
see um again saying free Palestine is
not does not make you a terrorist I say
free Palestine you know what I mean
let's go let's free Palestine it's the
timing what's so hard to understand
if the first thing after news
breaks that 700 people were
murdered is free is um I support
Palestine what does that mean that that
means something what does it mean that's
the first thing your thoughts
isn't like oh man uh wow a bunch of
civilians were murdered it's
um let's go let's do let's do more that
let's keep it going guys mhm not it's
got nothing to do with caring about the
freedom of Palestinian people just
saying it's like so obvious what
it
means don't act don't don't need to act
silly like that's not what it
means preemptive support for Palestine
is not endorsement for Hamas we knew
what was going to happen after October
7th regard right I I almost brought this
up as a potential explanation of people
realizing immediately what the
implication of these attacks are in
terms of the retaliation and the Hell
Fire that's going to be brought down on
Gaza as a result um which not wrong that
yes that is going to happen the news the
news is like they're still counting warm
dead body right yeah it's it's what
upset you sing still playing out and and
people were quick to rush to that but I
mean obviously this situation didn't
start this weekend and people have very
strong opinions about it um and so
you're right everybody was in quite a
rush to to get their take out there on
the internet um and I can see why that
upset you and and you're not wrong I
mean I some people some people are
openly celebrating it and you're not
wrong to be upset about that think that
there is Nuance there um for a lot of
people that like you just that chatter
that you just quoted saying that they
preemptively just issuing support to the
people in Palestine um for what
inevitably is going to uh be the result
of this which is probably just a full
scale Invasion at this point the other a
disturbing factor is the anniversary of
which it it happened on the 50 years of
the Yum kapore what happened 50 years
ago that that gives it such a um more
disturbing aspect to it you know
I
suppose
um there it
is Twitter is a rat
hole I say free Ohio free
Ohio so true we're talking about that's
what we're talking about right Palestina
Ohio yeah yeah yeah yeah where the train
crash happened we need to let them we
need to let them all
out
um
there it is I don't know what to
say um you know calling a calling a
group of terrorists in the act of
murdering people a Renaissance painting
and I mean these these tweets are not
these are being widely celebrated and
she's being like massively complimented
by I know that you gave that as an
example just because it it was a
disturbing one but um you know Mia
Khalifa isn't exactly like a I'm just
saying like the people she's getting
massive support yeah I mean yeah she
can't even return to her home country
because of stuff she's done I mean she
has disrespected uh her own religion in
multiple ways and her own people with
some of the she've said so yeah
she's well and then like doing she did
like the porn videos in like the hijab
the hijab that's what got them all crazy
mad at her right mhm in Lebanon by the
way you know I mean like who the f like
sh thank you
AB
yeah but yeah to add on to what Dan was
saying in response to uh saying I stand
with Palestine being a preemptive uh
action
also it could be in response to the way
they're being talked about online and
the way they have been talked about both
online and in real life like and again I
completely understand where you're
saying that uh it's
insensitive I'm saying from the other's
point of view is
that everyone is saying like look at
these animals these are these animals
acting like
animals the some of the people who are
posting this and I don't know I haven't
been on Twitter could just be saying
that I stand with the people not Hamas
who are now going to be roped in with
this because of these terrorist acts
right exactly those aren't the tweets
I'm talking
about there's an obvious difference
difference right but I think it's
important to emphasize because that did
seem to be why a lot of the push back
was coming from from our own chat of
people saying just because I said that
doesn't mean I mean you've made the
point you're saying it's about it the
the bodies aren't even cold yet and
let's talk about the minute the
the World Trade Center towers are hit
and collapse the first thing you're on
Twitter is saying I stand with Iraq I
know Iraq didn't do it but just using as
an example you know
um yeah that would be
really this stand with the you
know but there's a difference too I'm
not talking about people that are like
speaking with nuance and I'm not
saying you can't say stand with
Palestine and it's
obvious you're coming off as a baby
you're coming off as a
all right that's
it
[Applause]
[Music]
he anyway I'm just say I there's a
difference I mean I know people can say
that there's a difference I'm talking
about the ones of people that weren't
having Nuance takes about it right
but obviously you can say free Palestine
and not be a terror Pro terrorism that's
like what what the why are you
making me say
that
okay all right what else how can we uh
cleanse the pallet of a little
bit out this heavy thing heavy stuff I
see yeah that's a good
one a ring
Dinger very good thank you thank you
let's see what else we got
here what are we feeling the
um
the new Alpha Male just dropped for the
20th time the third time let's let's
what else we got well hold on where wait
there was the the the uh there was
another story that you were stoked
on but is that kid going to call in what
whatever happened with him you didn't he
he offered to call in tomorrow I said
we're not live tomorrow we're live today
can you call in and he didn't reply cuz
he kept saying like he could only do it
at night at a certain time I wasn't sure
I didn't do the time zone own
calculation yeah uh there he's in the UK
and many hours ahead so the evening is
when we're live but it was more a matter
of the day you can call in to see you
next Tuesday tomorrow it's I really want
to talk to him have one on one have a
heart to heart this show is at 9:00 for
him it's after his bedtime probably
after his bedtime that be true he does
have braces he's a he's a sleepy male or
snoozer male wait can we talk about
snoozer males oh yeah snoo Maes it's new
mail just dropped yeah actually um it's
just a meme by the way you know oh okay
I never but I think we should make it
real because I identify as a just alone
not Newser mail H yeah uh we didn't
include it because uh we found out it
was a meme oh okay yeah but I have the
actual video it's about sigmas if you
want that yeah the the original is just
a sigma thing but just a Sigma thing
which you know we're down with the sigma
males okay 15 signs you're a snoozer
male super rare and is that better than
Alpha it is but I want to watch his
video it's not a f video that's what I'm
trying to say but he posted it I thought
no no this is the actual no no it's just
a it's just a meme oh no so he's been
doing I've never what is snoozer mail
then it's just it's just something they
made up but what I'm trying to say is I
want to make it real it is real God damn
it it is real it's real to
this video is or this picture is so
funny with of him in the cap every time
I see it it's cing me up dude we
should look at him he's a sleepy guy he
looks like a little elf mhm he looks so
cute based in Sleepy pilled somebody
said
absolutely this is the original though I
love this guy 15 signs you're a sigma
male super rare and is it better than
Alpha I love him he's definitely going
to be copyrighted music in this you know
I checked it oh really yeah oh
let's see what he has to say real fast
this is my incredible price for a
limited time that code is only good for
a few days so if you're iny then started
today these 10 traits are what you must
possess in order to be amazing and
Kick-Ass at life number one is
selfesteem self-esteem is all about
respecting I mean so far probably not
that easy to just turn on though right
right like it's not that useful I cuz we
watched one of this guy's videos before
and I seem to recall you know he's sort
of he's a different type of alpha male
influencer he's not he seems to be
genuinely a nice guy yeah he was on
Shark Tank he's a little goofy was he
really yeah he's like one of those early
early age alpha males not the kind of
under Alpha M he's kind of he's like
dating coach he like yeah yeah which is
like not as like cursed yeah I mean it's
it's funnier it's less just like
horrible right but he says okay be
confident so there you go guys stop
being stop being not confident okay
right yourself and not doing stupid
and putting yourself in compromising
positions the second thing you need
gentlemen is pride pride in who you are
slow repetitive it's a little redundant
too much over like I I get it's a
distinct concept from self-esteem but
it's a little too close it's pretty
close as a man as a person but pride in
everything that you do I mean if we're
going to make Sigma male a distinct
category we need more more defined
states of being than pride pride and
confident we're going to have to work on
this number three is loyalty you need to
be loyal not only to your word like as
in like if you say something you better
do it you need to be loyal to people do
not stab people in the back do not talk
trash that's good advice okay yeah I
mean so far keep it loyal brother yeah
when when is this going to take a left
turn off a cliff that like the next one
you need to own your woman GHB carry it
at all
times no he's a he seems like a nice guy
to be honest about other people that are
supposed to be your friends number four
is compassion you need to be
compassionate for others one of the
things that really does not sound very
Alpha that is iner so this is refreshing
I love it shut up compassion is
beta well he's a sigma he's not Alpha
right right right right
right climate in world is that people
get so pissed off at other people for
being different just because somebody is
different than you believes different
things or might do different things or
live a different way doesn't mean that
you shouldn't like them doesn't mean
that you should talk down to him it
means that you need to be comp thanks
for all
boring I'd rather be snoo frankly I'd
rather be an Al he just snooze pilled
you snoo mail dude he melatonin you
yapping yapping
yapping so we were talking about
the he's on the hon Sho me the green the
dream concert tour is this
mean yeah but it's funny is it too mean
let's not be mean to dream go let's not
wait oh wait no he cheated on the world
record I always forget he did cheat in M
he's forever in my bad races
which is frankly uh you can't yeah speed
running it's it's an honor-based system
and to to cheat on that is true so
disgusting this is UN unforgivable he
deserves everything that Happ so let's
roast the out of him all right
let's do it he talked me into
it um no offense to him I guess but um
it's Li hard just going to peek at it a
little bit just a peek just a peek and
I'm going to be respectful I'm going to
be respectful he's out here he's doing
he's performing and you know hey that's
great he's following the sigma advice
he's being confident he's doing he's
being he's proud of himself right he's
not loyal to the rules of Minecraft
though right he's not being loyal not
not loyal to the
rules
true that's a paradox that sounds like a
snooze
mouth uh let me see let me see let me
see
here oh my God at some point big bus so
he's test driving a new song I guess
with the
audience
[Music]
me yes oh this is the funny moment
oh my God maybe it's not so much him but
just like the fandom I don't
know no there's nothing wrong with any
of these people they're all
sing what so is this a Dream
song yeah oh God wait we just played a
wait could I have played that yeah no it
was all good remember oh right right
right so this was something that was
really funny a fan put together a
compilation of good moments from dreams
concert but did they use a song per of
dream dreams no it was uh something
called the wombat they didn't use the
damn they didn't use a Dream song it
wasn't good enough for the for the super
edit wasn't Snappy
enough uh this isn't the one I wanted to
watch though the unreleased song this is
the one song is so goed I just have a
these hooks get stuck in my head is
all 2 1
I you're
noted not there not there you got to
pull all these Z not there not there
dream when you're not there not there
not there you got to please grab those
these are going to be I'm sensing huge
Sound by potential here I'll come
through it thank you brother I know you
will when you're not there wait wait
your turn ready ready 2
1 right up to the monitor bre when
you're not not there you're not there
you're
not can't sleep it's a Nightmare
[Music]
2 nightm a nightmare a nightmare this is
a tough one a concert or kindergarten
class he's just doing new material man
hell yeah whoa that shit's sick Dan
hating this is a whole I mean what's
wrong with this I love dream I love his
fans it's all wholesome Dan's the one
hating I didn't do
anything I think this is awesome he's
only going to get better yeah's yeah
right right it's just new material come
on
guys you're
not that's terrible it's all up from
here I think it's exciting nowhere to go
but up from here it's real best
m not there not there he really needs
him to hit that part I can't dream when
you're not there you're asking a lot
from the audience and they did pretty
good but it's not enough you need some
to go not there not there no you guys
are too unkey you got you're notat
enough he's like no I need you guys to
hit this really weird part here hit that
vocal break
[Music]
not not there not there head go num and
my heart beats fast when itss like that
okay that was not bad at
all he's a good singer he's got a good
voice it's the stage presence he's it's
gonna it's going to build the stage
presence he's he's making he's forming
the foundation right now right um here
he is licking CDs before he sends them
out to fans I don't know what this means
but I just saw it and I thought hey
let's share it anyway um I'm he said he
says that is so funny I'm licking the
next 100
[Laughter]
orders what do yall think about
[Music]
that so incidentally the uh Raffle
winners I licked I sharked it in all the
shirts yeah that we sent out so bro that
audio is so sick where does it come from
oh was so funny the sound the sound is
so funny it's like a fog horn Spong a
fog horn yeah I was going to say from
old like cartoons so maybe SpongeBob I
feel like probably even older than that
I think it's just like a stock stock
horn we could get a uh F horn going Zach
I want the fog
horn that's my favorite not there it
sounds similar to a singing voice yeah
but it's just
so oh I love it that's crazy do you
remember that Viral clip of du alipa on
stage where the the famous comment Go On
Girl give us nothing mm she was like
notorious she was famous for like not
having stage presence and girle went to
the studio came back she's a superstar H
Can Dream dance reveal I know I know she
has this thing where she goes it's that
one yeah that was the video I got to say
it's not that impressive yes that was
the Go On Girl give us nothing hold on
oh that's what she's saying that was the
one that wasn't good she had a blank
face and she was just going like this
like us I thought people were loving
that well it's a meme now we love that
what is it it's like this yeah cuz she
would just stand there and do this right
okay okay cuz I I saw a ton of clips of
that and I was like what yeah listen I
mean I guess they're pretty twisty hips
I no that's dream on this tour not there
dreams the next du alipa yeah I feel
that I can't wait when you're not he's
gonna go on BAC all the time
not
there I love Bahamas anyway thank you
thank you with peace and love to
everybody to all people of the world um
I've got
some James Charles being bothered by
seeing people grow up but just tries to
show off his vocal skills oh God this is
so
embarrassing why is he doing this why
are you like this
James
why are you like this right
now if I see one more video on my for
you page going it's a new da it's a new
day it's a new life for
me and I'm
feeling good with some photos
when you were like I I don't that was
so yep I was hoping that would happen I
was so sick yeah that was quick man good
pull wow here's the
thing it's so obvious that he did this
just because he thought he was badass
singer yeah it's just so uncomfortable I
didn't it's like I don't think anybody
knows what he's even talking about for
being a grown right just give us the
song just sing yeah just sing you don't
have to lie to kick
it just be yourself dude don't hide
behind this and everyone in the comments
for some reason is going there's no way
that's same person oh my God glow up
obviously that's how growing stop
yelling at you don't look the same oh
I'm going to ler that is so weird you
need help
brother you need professional help
you're yelling wa that's such a
self-report James wishes they could stay
young forever yeah that's the comment it
is kind of he's like yeah I know people
grow up and I wish they wouldn't I wish
they'd all
stop not there
not when you're not there not
there uh you know lots of love lots of
fun for the Britney Spears knife
play
um here it is oh no this was ER rased it
was work of art John
Wick someone made a John
Wick uh Britney Spears knife mashup
Lally just check it too here let me see
why would you why would you erase
this damn that's what I feel in my heart
right
now uh I don't know if we talked about
it
but
um during the there was like a emergency
broadcast test that I think everybody
got it in the country was it everybody
in the country that's pretty
intense and there was a group of people
that truly believed that the the
frequency the tone would activate the
5G or Co shots and turn us into zombies
or something like genuinely genuinely
turn off your C on October 4th the EBS
is going to test the system using 5G
this will activate the mar buug virus
and people who have been vaccinated and
sadly turn some of them into zombies
this is real and I know it sounds like
parody but it is
real here's a
story of a landlord who turned off the
power through his whole
building to protect them let's see
everyone not sure if this is a text from
Gary the landlord everyone not sure if
you have heard that there will be an
emergency broadcast this Wednesday at
2:20 it seems most don't know I've been
following this for the last few weeks
and the concern has been brewing about
it I was going to text everyone about it
today thinking it just thinking to just
suggest avoiding all communication
devices cell computer TV and radio for
everyone especially the coid vaccinated
for some reason I can't get into this
message but I'm happy to elaborate with
the links for any part you may be
wondering about but now I'm learning I'm
also learning that even worse Mo
come on Ethan
thank you but now I'm learning that even
most newer appliances may be at
risk um so we have decided not for not
only everybody's safety but also the
safety of all of our multiple appliances
we furnish for all the apartments to
possibly have to replace nearly 100
appliances on Thursday doesn't sound
like a risk we are willing to take I
don't understand that why why is the is
the appliance going to be turned into a
zombie um we apologize for any
inconvenience this may cause but we feel
be in everyone's best interest for the
whole building to be shut down for a
brief 2hour period on
Wednesday yeah
what the problem is the phones I thought
and the and the and the the 5G signal
that's being sent out the kill grid
they're switching on the kill grid yeah
yeah I don't know what turning off your
toaster maybe he's just trying to
justify it well I mean if you believe
that's gonna happen I feel like it's
logical to do that just in case like if
you actually the phon the turning off
the power of the building won't turn off
people's phones can never be too safe
brother never be too
safe what is that going to accomplish I
mean obviously it's not going to
accomplish anything anyways but that's
my point even by what he's saying it
doesn't make any sense I guess so he
says Frozen items should be fine if you
leave them in the freeze closed it's all
a solid block of ice keeping it nice and
cold in there no worries no worries it
will be daylight so no need for lights
either it is also recommended that you
inform others of the situation for the
vaccinated it may be even more
potentially fatal we apologize even more
fatal potentially well fatal
ISAT the end point yeah you can't be
more or less
fatal right uh we apologize for any
inconvenience good thing it's only for a
short two hours if you are here I highly
recommend you not just turn the power
off with your cell phone but turn the
Wi-Fi and cell reception
off this is crazy Carrie I work from
home I cannot have my power shut on
three
hours if the building went out in the
building in a store oh my God Gary Gary
what are you doing why are you doing
this
Gary so there you go pretty fun Gary's a
legend bro the RO of a lifetime
Gary so
true kind of awesome though he's like
listen y'all I've been on a Facebook
group and it's got me thinking I need to
shut down the power I wonder how many
apartments are in there I'm shutting
down the power for all 20 units it's for
your own good don't worry your freezer
foods will be
fine love you Gary wow Legend that's
awesome apparently related multiple
Amish people were caught out after the
emergency alert revealed their secret
cell phones oh no they were caught out
outed and humiliated wait is this real
yeah yeah yeah what I know this guy this
guy's real interesting he's like a ex
Amish he lives near them and he he has
all kinds of tea on him okay out here in
Amish smoking big dos and Amish awesome
my Amish buddies shunned today by the
Amish Church oh boy that's right this
right
here right the test he's showing over
the years there's been quite a few Amish
men that reached out and wed phone so
whenever they request to have a phone
okay so I know this guy's actually a
really interesting cool dude He makes
himself available to Amish people that
may need a phone for whatever reason for
help a lot maybe they're being abused I
don't know he's a really a really
altruistic nice thing he does do
everything I can to try to get them a
phone not always can I do so but in some
circumstances I have been able to get
them a phone now three of them reply
back to me today and said hey I'm going
to have to lay low for a while I just
got shunned and I said how'd that happen
they said hey that emergency alert that
went off yeah we had our phones on
vibrate damn and it still went
off the one guy said the the elders were
coming in his driveway and they were
there to speak with him about something
that they heard about him that he might
have to get shunned you know they got to
chck up on it to see if it's true right
when that was going on the alert went
off and he was in his pocket now he's
getting shun for both whatever they were
after to shun him and also the cell
phone what is shun what what does that
what does it mean when they shun he is
incredible at telling a story he's the
man he he does seem like a cool guy his
name his Twitter is Yoder toer 40 like
he he shows he has Tik toks where he
hides phones under bridges and stuff and
then there's like a cash of money and he
trades the phone versus money oh yeah
awesome yeah this guy's pretty cool um
Yoder
toer Yoder toer Ford
here let me find one with a lot of views
that we can watch here this one has
200,000 guys I figured it's time for fin
old dress when I was growing up this is
the dress that I was we this is 6
minutes I'm not what I wanted here today
I built these Gates on here by the pool
with this battery drill but if I would
have been Amish where I grew up this man
just hates the omic bro he left
and he just he's out for
blood he's giving them phones he's using
drills it's out of
control this is what I would have had to
use to put my screws
in and Amish I want to show you the
difference in a worldly drill yeah no I
see it it's a big difference man is the
plug dud where's the phone anyway okay
whatever thank you shout out to Yoder
toorish yod toer so are you not are you
not familiar with that uh practice of
shunning Community shunning I mean I
don't what does it mean he's getting
double
shunned like they have to leave well
he's just I think he was just sort of
joking double
sh there's only one degree of uh of
shunning he was just saying for two
reasons they're being shun yeah but so
they leave right they just leave uh sort
of I mean it's sort of like being
excommunicated from your uh Community
like they they basically everybody in
the community stops talking to you and
you're like not allowed to be around
them anymore it's like kicking them out
of the community essentially cuz the
Amish don't really have they don't you
know they don't really have plan B's I
don't
think not going to go get a job at
Target or something yeah I don't know I
I yeah I think it is kind of a pretty
up thing
actually go ahead well some Amish
communities every single one they
interpret the rules via singular
community and the community in my
college they allowed the women to work
at a cafe and they allowed the men to
work construction jobs so like they
could work heavy machinery and that but
only when they were making their money
and then in their like personal time
that's when they did it so they get that
guacamole yeah it it's itend there's
just like kind of a I think there's a
lot of um I think it's a a wide range of
how uh it's how the elders right
Progressive each particular uh Community
is I think some are very traditional
still and really will not allow any sort
of electricity or any sort of modern
here anything here I've got the official
Amish basket.com some people even oneop
shop to get around the rules of no phone
in the house some people like made Rigs
and wired up on the outside of their
house and then they would like talk
outside the window that sounds fun kind
of Amish shutting rules are immensely
fascinating to the outside world but
what exactly are they and how does
shunning work the Amish have a unique
culture rich with many dos and don'ts
that's a rich with many dos and don'ts
that's a nice way to put it a wonderful
T tapestry of things that you can never
do or be removed from our community if a
member of an Amish community willingly
violates agreed upon rules they may be
shunned what does that mean precisely
this article details what shunning means
okay let's get right into it shunning
involves a painful separation of a
person from their Community person is no
longer allowed to eat or take rides with
the other community members they're not
even allowed to give people gifts
anymore well that's no problem for
me you're not allowed to give people
gifts anymore that sounds
easy just no you just don't do it
anymore you just it's like one thing you
don't do generally speaking they're not
included in any community activities
despite popular belief the person isn't
cut off entirely the community will
still converse with them and give help
or absolutely so it sounds like they get
to live they stay and live there they're
just being Outcast for a Time mhm all
the exact procedures may vary shining is
widely considered key to maintaining the
Integrity of the Amish
Church very interesting I'm G to have to
start shunning you guys one by one is
that why I'm not allowed to eat that's
right your cam is being shunned
no food you have that button under your
desk that's kind of like uh being
shunned like sometimes when you the
crowd are shunning yeah when you
sometimes yeah go ahead Dam what were
you
saying go
ahead
but go ahead talk you have permit Shan
stop I think I think what he would stop
shunned you're shunned stop don't even
try Olia stop
shunned okay I'm trying to make a point
go ahead Olivia you can finish your
point I didn't really have much Sean
stop it's all I needed what about uh
when hey you can't double shun me dude
I'm already you're double shun he's
double sh triple shun me you can't
quadruple sh me I'm what are your
thoughts you can speak I like you I like
what Zach has to say about things no
okay you're good you're all good I mean
you know if you really want to uh
stunned stop I didn't like where that
was going
stunned uh why do people get shunned
for wanting too much snacks in the
kitchen I don't know it's easy for
Outsiders to misunderstand the reasons
it's an act of
love Yeah are known for their focus on
living as a family so what are we why
are we shunning people they're not when
does shunning occur
shining shunning rules can come on just
tell me what I want to
know um after confession the person may
be temporarily shunned for 6 weeks it
sounds kind of like a vacation like you
don't nobody talks to you you don't have
to do anything it's a little more
upsetting you don't have to give anyone
gifts I see where right I see where
you're coming for you it might be a
vacation yeah we can shun you if you'd
like we can just stop paying attention
to you I mean it doesn't sound that bad
frankly I'm about to get shun after to's
up you you you're not allowed to help
them do excruciating construction jobs
oh boy shun me
again after six week the status quo is
returned All Is Forgiven it's actually
rare for a person to be shunned from an
Amish community but it's still
intriguing you know people may uh in the
Amish community may find what you're
saying uh offensive or upsetting but
they can't say anything because then
they doubt themselves as uh being online
watching watching right so then first
isn't it I can say whatever I want about
the Amish because one they'll I know
they're never going to hear it and if
they do they're shunned gotcha I'm
shunning you hey Amish guess what
you're shunned I'm going to tell your uh
Clap Your Leader your Amish leader
mhm what do they
called huh elders elders an elder yeah
that's also kind of dope I like that
title Elder I took um a religion class
when I was at school cuz I just wanted
to like meet people and part of it was
like we went to a service for like
somewhere in town and I went to an LDS
service and there were a bunch of EX
Amish people and I got to ask questions
about that's how I that's how I know a
little something did you ask them about
shunning um spec I mean I did I didn't
necessarily ask the word but they talked
about it cuz really yeah they have
something called rum Springer you know
about rum
Springer what's rum Springer oh you
don't know about rum Springer party time
you ever watch that show Breaking Amish
no I watched it it's a good show oh yeah
they have a tradition when uh young
people come of age right or when they
turn 18 oh that's when they go they go
on a a they're essentially allowed to go
live outside of the community for a
while and um and see if they like it and
and they get to live the non-amish
lifestyle for a little while yeah I know
and they get to I love this
movie both or King oh God damn it
kingpin kingin You just say BofA the
bowling movie yeah Kingpin the bowling
movie I love that movie dude he
does an often often springa or whatever
you said rer I wonder how many people
actually come
back from what I've heard although I
don't know for sure I think a
surprisingly high amount of them do I
think so too yeah because you if you
don't come back then you can't see your
loved ones it's all or it's all or
nothing if you don't come back come back
or you leave the community forever or
you get double sh per so um if y'all
haven't seen this it's one of these
movies this movie in so long dude it's
very funny it's got Bill Murray yeah and
this one guy who's Amish he's doing his
journey but he's like a sick
bowler and um the second funniest
bowling movie of the 90s ishir
what's better
ishill what's a better bowling movie
than Kingpin from 1990 oh it's not this
is really a true bowling
movie The Bow is a
lot a lot more than bowling
okay um it's funny it's so absurd so
silly could this maybe take this off the
screen even without sound I feel like it
might get IDE all right let's move on to
something important Mariah Carey has
this infamous 911 video she says uh-uh
nobody wants nobody wants to talk about
911 no no go ahead Z we're going to talk
a
little well you don't want to hear about
911 okay so weird like what's even the
context why did she say it nobody
understands now somebody all of a sudden
put out the full video here it is it's
got a lot of new context a lot of
different layers to this never before
seen footage people go never before seen
footage of the towers of the plane
hitting the towers no never before seen
footage of Mariah Carey talking about
9/11 last
year it was only two weeks ago I'm
trying to
tell well you don't want to hear about
911 that was just such a
disaster and I so she's reading a
teleprompter Pro
prompter and this is what's interesting
here she's trying I think she was really
confused everyone's confused as
hell she didn't bring it up randomly she
was surprised when it appeared on the
teleprompter and was reacting to trying
to to recover on the fly so was she
telling them nobody wants to hear about
911 that's my interpretation but I don't
quite understand because she would
presumably not be surprised by the
script of her own show it's almost worse
this video almost makes it worse it does
that mean she's like yo nobody wants to
hear about that
let's keep
[Music]
watching we're going to talk a little
bit about see they went back
up this moment it was only two weeks ago
that we remembered um okay oh brother so
I just want to we all here together okay
I'm going to get through and then we're
going to sing a song for you and be out
but just want to say
that as most of us so certainly I would
assume all of literally anybody who's
taking a public speaking class knows
what this is realizing you have no idea
what you're saying and everyone is
watching you feels like what it was only
two weeks ago that we remembered the
tragedy that she's a little bit more
experienced of public speaking than some
Community College Student that is taking
speech 101 just a little bit she right
been a one of the biggest pop stars in
the world for like 30 Years also baby
mama to Nick Canon
Baby M who Nick Cannon right she's one
of the lucky men one of the lucky 18s B
twins so here's this she obv is she I
don't know that she obviously didn't
know it was coming which yes she handled
it awkward but she's not a trained
talking head what why is this person's a
Mariah Carey apologist Google news
anchor bloopers if you want to see how
awkward it can be what what are we
running the for Mariah Carey so hard any
of us have ever forgotten it you know I
I was honored to have played a little
teeny part in the aftermath of that day
as my song Hero so natural such a
touching
tribia became one of the unofficial
anthems whatever and and did I have to
admit I I have a hard time acknowledging
my own stuff but whatever um it there's
full I don't think anyone in the
audience knows what's
happening there it is so
she's and this person's mind acquitted
but in our
minds not acquitted what's the opposite
she's recharged she's being recharged
for higher crimes that's been our
Collective loss and our recovery Rec
she's being double shun you can't be uh
it's double
jeopardy I learned from another '90s
movie that you can't be charged for the
same crime
twice it's a remember that movie
Harrison it's one of the stupidest
Double Jeopardy stupidest concept
that is a great movie Dan I
remember it she gets framed for like her
husband's murder but he faked the death
and secretly like went to another
country or something and then she finds
out that she gets out of jail and finds
out that he's still alive and she
realizes you can't be charged for the
same crime twice so it's all Mur and she
took the he took the kid too he took her
kid hold on hold on that's Epic
no you got to watch he's already been
charged with his murder so they can't
charge her again and did she get off I
don't no well yeah in the movie I think
so but that that's not how that would
work are you sure I'm pretty sure I
don't know I think that would be
considered a separate crime it's one of
the Jud sisters and uh how many times
can you kill someone
Dan just once you're right she already
served the time what zacho one of the
Jud sisters plays the lead character was
the Ashley Jud Ashley Jud uh Dennis uh
Quaid isn't it I think it's Tommy Lee
Jones in the movie Tommy that's so weird
cuz Tommy Lee Jones it made me think of
The Fugitive which is a Harrison
fordon it was probably in yeah I mean
these kind of like Thrillers like this
were very popular in the 90s The
Fugitive let's see let's see I I spoiled
uh Kyle XY earlier I'm going to spoil
Double Jeopardy right now so spoiler
everybody dude uh I'm looking at the
plot synopsis
here all I remember from The Fugitive is
Harrison Ford saying a million times you
killed my wife I didn't kill my wife or
want my family back he says I didn't
kill my wife I don't care that's what he
said I don't
care dude he was old even back then damn
dude he ate that roll up it was both of
them where's Tommy Lee Jones I haven't
seen him in a minute that guy was the
king back then uh he was super popular
for a while there he was in Men In Black
3 for the wait he was men and black won
one through three yeah he was so good in
men and black where is he he in this one
he was too old so they did a time travel
thing and Josh broland played a younger
version of him it looks like his last
movie was Ad Astra which end up seeing
he won an
Oscar for The Fugitive I don't know
let's see nominated for
Lincoln oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he
was um wasn't he John Quincy The
Fugitive he won an Oscar for Fugitive
best supporting actor wow he was very
good in that wow and
nominated as well always but see I'll
tell you this always the uh hand made
and never the Bri or what is it always
the hand always the brides made always
the brides made never the bride they're
all supporting roles uh the valley
of best performance by an oh leading
role oh yeah the valley of ela boom
he's a bride now boom
okay we're getting married no country
great in that
movie right oh yeah how we forget
amazing yeah oh man I love him I
think he's just really old and he's just
not as active anymore he's 77 currently
he did a bunch of like ads in Japan too
that's awesome I love when oh I've seen
those very funny Tommy Lee Jones man
come on give us another classic come on
Tommy one more more Road I know you got
it in you you want to get him on the Pod
we got to get him and Harrison Ford back
together for some other 9s comedy thr or
crime Thriller oh he played thus Stevens
in
Lincoln yeah let's reach out let's get
Tommy Lee and let's get him in here yeah
let's get him in it let's film The
prolapse Harrison might be hard but I
feel like we could get
Tommy there's 0% chance but let's see
maybe you can do
it uh oh we have a video um
that we' made an Ode to the apology
Podium that I broke in a fit of drunk
rage still so sad where's that linked at
because I see
it okay oh we were just GNA play it full
so um the apology Podium it's been with
us a long time and it's been through
quite a lot it's seen a lot oh yeah MH
and apologies well in a sense it's the
end of an era and let's honor it
[Music]
today we have brought in this Podium
because there's a lot of apologies being
issued lately it was uh appropriate to
bring out an apology Podium a somber
place a sober place a place of
reflection quiet reflection and uh soul
searching where we can issue the most
deepest and heartfelt apologies to
anyone who who was offended or made even
a little bit uncomfortable by anything
we said because that's totally never our
um intentions here on the H podcast the
greatest show in the world ever made I
apologize what am I apolog I apologize
for making anyone uncomfortable with bad
jokes I apologize to my cleaning lady
who I left a giant streak in the
toilet on the way out I want to
apologize to ELA whose birthday it is on
Thursday for getting cancelled on her
birthday week ologies to ELA I just want
to apologize to the Koreans the
everybody who's a fan of the K-pop World
clearly ignorant to to the uh intri
Ines pass that part and let me just say
this BTS forever Stan K-pop love
Korea love everybody I'm talking
I'm talking BTS it's all love here from
the A3 podcast we see you and I can't
wait for the squid gamees game show is
coming
out it's going to be sick yeah on on
Netflix they're doing a squid games game
show which weird they're doing a squid
game game show a real game show on
N which is like this weird Inception
that Mr Beast made a game show about
squid games right and I that can't be
where they got the the idea was I mean
they're basically just doing the Mr
Beast thing but does you think they
really got the idea from him cuz it's
like pretty obvious let's make a game
show yeah I mean I yeah huh are people
going to die I think so I has to be true
to the book I hope so but I just wanted
to say and let's not play any more of
that Ian okay I see what you're doing
and I don't appreciate it you're no
you're apologizing what's the problem no
no no no skip it and let's forget about
it you had a short lapse in judgment I
did I love them I love butter it's my
favorite single smooth like butter
Dynamite Boy an ice cream black pink
Selena Gomez beautiful oh forget it it
doesn't get better than that doesn't get
better Ariana was a writer on that
doesn't get better
doesn't it's smooth like butter
is and you know listen yeah it is butter
is like it's real smooth as smart as
smooth things go I think butter smooth
baby I think butter it's like butter
baby absolutely smooth all right we
ready I'm cooking I'm cooking out here
Ian play the thing all right
take it away you know that
I you know just so ashamed that I had to
get canceled on Twitter Again Sam You
are Loved You Are
appreciated you are
seen I'm well aware of your
name your name is
Sam it is I know exactly who you are
it'll never happen again
okay thank you I apologize to the cats
of course you are worthy of love you are
great pets Google this ABY how many cat
owners have
toxoplasmosis but that's just a fact
that's not I'm not expressing an opinion
about cats I'm not saying I don't like
them that's just a fact guys this is the
worst apology I'm not I didn't start my
apology yet I apologize to all the cat
owners out there that I may have
offended anyway peace and love peace and
love I come before you today as a
reformed hater ass what have you
done honestly that's so bad you goof
made some Goofs here and there but who
has in influencers that have been on the
internet with that broad of an audience
we've all put our foot in our mouth or
done stupid what crime was
committed we have to change our way we
can't continue to tear each other down
like this okay I felt
like I felt like at times in my career
I've been dog piled on and I've asked
myself what have I done what crime have
I committed right to be getting this
much hate mhm like I've never I've never
done anything really bad have
I
nope no and so like I feel that and yet
I put that pain on others and it's not
okay but the truth this ninja you're a
good guy man I think you're a great
fortnite player and we all love you here
addiction starts with admitting you're
an addict and I'm a hater ass this
one's for you
ninja this has been an apology from
Ethan
Klein I want to point out that Ethan did
just break the podium Podium
what stop that means no more apologies
baby you're free what the thought
that's
expensive
give W
[Music]
ready thank you 100% true at the end
there wow now first of
all the the real tragedy is that I have
nothing uh to apologize on
to the apology Podium uh we are truly
lost but in an interesting twist cam I
like what you did there what we have
ever been
cancelled if not for the apology Podium
that's a good
question what was the first one even for
I was those before it was in a viewer
what's that Cameron why' you guys buy
the apology podium in the first place it
was the laugh you lose thing cuz I think
we just thought it was funny that people
were so angry at
me yeah I guess that maybe was before or
the uh the K-pop one I was thinking it
was the K-pop one but I think it it was
the laugh you lose we had been doing a
lot I had been doing a lot of apologies
so was kind of in the air I totally
forgot about that laugh you lose it was
because you you you
cheated that people were upset was that
it I don't know I guess I'm just not I
just was annoying so I saw one comment
I'm 12 minutes in and Ethan has ruined
it I guess I'm just annoying
you know right it was that you were
replaying your videos cuz nobody would
laugh and then you play it again until
somebody laughed and people thought that
was we should do another one by the way
people have been clamoring for another
laugh you lose I I I have a folder of
videos that I add to throughout the
whole year I'm already ready really yeah
well because the first couple years we
did it I would always like stay up till
3: in the morning the night before
looking for funny videos so in I I got
smart about it and just if I see
something I'm like oh this would be good
for it I just throw it throw it in a
full that's interesting see usually I
share it with the
podcast well all the one they're they're
all just like one-off videos that
wouldn't
be usually I uh you want to watch some
put thatp I can pull them open no save
them I I got to say I'm proud of my
performance in the last one the Jay Leno
edit I mean really J Leno I got that's
probably the funniest video that's ever
been pulled out wow thank you again yeah
thanks brother means so much for you to
with one
exception what's that you
know I know would you like me to pull it
up I don't know a funnier video I think
I know should I guess is the grass
Clipper is it supposed to be so oh yeah
this
one I don't think I think every year
you've done the same year and it always
works I don't know it's
just it's so crazy that is a good ass
video
man yeah we need to do one soon let's
let's do one soon well we always do it
for Thanksgiving which is next month oh
is that the tradition yeah it's the
Thanksgiving tradition it's coming right
up coming right
up here's the I found the Britney Spears
um knife edit
that's so
[Music]
awesome that's crazy
good what the
wow wow that's God Dam wait there's
a whole bunch of them I'm
seeing okay I can't hear the
music okay I'm I um get out update from
uh way way earlier in the show when you
were asking how many k-pops were brought
in by uh by Ally it was 12 that's it she
said 12 now here's the thing a lot it's
a lot and I'm curious I never I didn't
have any I I never got my hands on one
did anybody else hear eat one me and
Lena had one each you had one each so
that's 10 I had I only had one you said
you kept eating no I just had no I just
had a bunch of them I only had I had one
you said you had five you just said I
had a eat them all they were just in
front of me
oh got it kind of savage monster you
think I am yeah how little you think of
me
uh how long we've been going cuz we
started on time we've been going for 3
hours almost 20 3 hours 20 oh my God I'm
actually going to get home at a normal
time wow this is
exciting we like started on time today
too pretty nice to start on time isn't
it is that isn't it really nice isn't it
nice well first of all I was in my
seat
and I'm just saying we were a few
minutes late well okay just saying it is
nice it'd be nice Dan let me say this
let me say this as someone that's
punctual let me say this I'd appreciate
it isn't it nice when we can start on
time Dan's back here
you're a funny guy
Ethan thanks
Zach go ahead Dan yeah it' be nice if we
could start on
time you know I sat here for what 2 or 3
minutes waiting for you oh
no I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry wait a couple minutes as someone
who's newly punctual I
appreciate you
f you
know yeah two or 3 minutes is is a world
you know it's everything all
right it's so nice though isn't it it is
isn't it nice it is nice Zach stop
saying
that it is nice it's real
nice real nice what else do we have
anything else to hit on real fast I was
going to go till 4:30 so we got 10
minutes uh um we watch the the the alpha
bro guy I don't remember what I said
about
him um I wonder if I'll make the same OB
if you get into it it's going to be a
whole thing cuz there there's a bunch
here I just like the Africa
one where's the Africa one that's my
favorite uh it can we can we show the
number five you really like this Africa
one huh it's
funny oh here okay apologies cuz you
probably guys heard this but I got to
set it up for my boy cuz he might be
calling in so he he put out this Tik to
uh feminine men are destroying society
and used a picture of
me destroying the world because we have
a purpose to fulfill so anyway he goes
on and on why are you a feminine man
like there's lots of things that you can
say about you but feminine I don't I
don't really get get like there are
other examples ofin you know feminine
presenting men I mean I'm heterosexual
yeah I have three I have boys I only
have boys right and you're like sitting
here in this picture with like a full
beard it's like you're not like
presenting feminine in any way it's not
super well thought out but I am curious
to ask him but here's my favorite one
the Africa one I don't know if we
watched this on Friday I have a feeling
I was saying the same thing on that we
didn't watch it I don't remember this is
such an iconic video I love it
so much this kid with braces I love
homeless is censored what the is it
that's hard that is bad is supposed to
be like I think he's he's just trying to
be cool for the
algo homeless is a bad is a naughty word
on Tik Tok is he scared it's like the
other word that if there were to be like
whatever that's not your an opening line
this already
I want to emphasize though like I'm not
actually don't want to make fun of him
I'm genu I genuinely want to have a
conversation and understand him like I I
feel like we can make a positive
influence on on his life maybe I'm
curious you know sure but here he is uh
in the most convincing uh words possible
drop me in Africa with no food no water
no house nothing and watch me come out
in a private jet you don't have
that already and you're
have
food I just can't get over he's got
braces that are definitely paid by his
parents he's talking real quiet so he
doesn't wake up nana I I feel I agree I
feel bad for the dude no I'm I I'm my
heart is with him I I think he he wants
acceptance and this is his way of trying
to Branch into that and this is what he
grew up with seeing these Alpha Bros and
he's like oh well maybe if I do that I
can get friends but it's not going to
work brother yeah well the thing is too
like you know it's obviously encouraging
him him to do some healthy activities
like working out and taking care of
himself in that regard that's good yeah
you can do that you don't have to make
it your whole life see that that's what
I'm preaching that's my pilgrimage
that's my missionary
work you know normalize working out but
not talking about it you know it doesn't
have to be your whole it's okay if it is
but I'm just saying it seems to be that
it needs to be your entire personality
needs to be that you go to the
gym also he he isn't dealing with any of
the problems that he listed and he still
doesn't have a private jet that's what I
mean it's all going on for you brother
like things are things are looking up
and you how do you still not have it
let's work on getting a private jet in
in UK okay then then we'll go to the
Africa drop air drop doesn't even have a
drop he probably does even know how to
parachute probably just Splat on the
ground yeah we need to get our facts
straight before before we go to Africa
let's go back again drop me in Africa
with no food no water no house nothing
and watch me come out in a private
I mean the balls The Audacity Of
The Claim is so
fantastic oh man put me in a prison so
for 10 years and watch me come out with
animal that I believe I mean
prison's not good for the psyche and a
lot of times all they all that you can
do is exercise so um sure I believe that
ready to take every single UFC belt in
every single division this is my mindset
no matter the condition or the situation
or my emotions I will overcome and
adapt I'm vibing with him I like him
sick I I really genuinely want
to pick his brain drop me in
Africa and I'll come out with a private
jet my boys said this to me they said
they were concerned for me and they
didn't like what I was doing wa wait
that was my other favorite one possible
sign of success my said wait okay hold
on I'll pull this one up this is my
other
fav I feel bad I they said God damn it
why is the play bar so
small my boys said this to me they said
they were concerned for me and they
didn't like what I was doing this is the
greatest possible sign of
success that was such an interesting
take to me everybody's super worried
about me in my
life they're begging me to stop and to
listen to
reason that's the greatest sign of
success a person can ask for is that
everybody close to them is begging them
to
stop please they ask they say to me
please don't do this you're hurting
yourself you're hurting your family to
me we love you please don't go down this
road that's the greatest sign of success
you know I feel like he he's kind of
creating a really good satire of these
kind of videos um unintentionally maybe
maybe there there's a niche there maybe
you could switch it up and just actually
lean into the satire angle some of these
are really funny yeah I when I
first showed this to Dan he thought it
was parody but I had to assure him this
this kid is is the one that really got
me
this one felt a little bit like parody
and but the the one where he talks about
uh the black plague being like 100 years
ago or whatever I was like where's that
one let me pull that up
um see here they think I'm insane they
think I'm mental with what I'm doing so
they can see that every single day I am
just doing such different things to what
they and average people do they like
what the actual is he doing it's
like why isn't he going to parties why
isn't he playing video games why isn't
he doing all this stuff why is he
sleeping for 4 hours a day why is he bro
he is not a snoozer male I need to help
this poor guy there's just that you
don't have to do this to yourself man
you
know you're being you're you're
being fed false
promises I got you bro working 20 hours
a day why is he training
for 3 hours a day this is not normal
this is mentally insane we need to pull
him back and bring him back make sure
he's
okay see even that one too the fact that
it just cuts off without like I was
expecting him to like give a retort to
that but it just kind of he just
explains how everyone thinks he's insane
and then that's the end of the that
rules that's awesome if you're depressed
it's because you're lazy this is the
one okay put on we have to put up the I
don't
condone because it's like a mental
health thing and oh YouTube's a little
sensitive apologies to you um we're not
yeah I mean this is a stock graphic we
have we're not calling you I have to do
it for for YouTube uh this song is a if
you have talk it didn't get claimed oh
okay if we checked okay you guys ready
enough you guys ready for this wisdom to
drop yeah ready if you're depressed it's
because you're lazy if that's the crazy
most
awesome advice ever
man you have time to think that you're
depressed or think that you're sad
you're lazy you think that our ancestors
in the 1800s so whenever it was that
they were going through things like the
black plague or slavery hold on did he
really let me let me go or in the Stone
Age when they had hundreds or whenever
it was that they were going 1800s it was
a lot further or whatever it was 500
years yeah we're only off by about 500
years 600 years it was in like 1500 I
think about no like 1300s oh was all
right here let's see that's a what an
iconic plague what a
plague still known to this day let see
black death there you go 13 1346 oh man
you are way
off just just 500 years or that was the
Cil War bro there's there was no
overlap whenever it was that they were
going for a fin like the black plague or
slavery or in the slavery or
slavery slaves weren't depressed they
were too busy doing
stuff Al I have a I don't know his
background so I can't say this
definitively but I'm a little skeptical
that his ancestors were
enslaved yeah don't make assumptions
Dan age when they had to survive do you
think they got depressed no they didn't
get depressed I love that he knows
probably I know my answer to that would
be yeah probably he he poses this
rhetorical question that is like be
so he but he knows the answer he goes no
obviously were people ever depressed
before now
no I
mean and we're we're were slaves
depressed no they were too busy they
were
too Liv sound
like some probably were that's like a
Gary ve wisdom he goes you know what's
better than being born free born a slave
gives you
perspective yeah Gary ve would say that
perspective Gary ve say you're
idiot firstly because they didn't
believe in it so they couldn't get
depressed and secondly what they tell
you that what are you talking about
again this this is the one where I was
like no shot is this guy serious he is
man
he's very knowledgeable yeah he has a
time
machine he did a systematic survey of
all all people dating back to 1300s and
and present day black plague he was
there how were you feeling during the
black day when all of your family died
of the plague tell me were you depressed
or were you too busy I was too busy I
was too busy uh carrying out the dead
and burning them I didn't have time I
just time to really be sad about it you
know
and once they were burned I had to just
you know go make food I had to go hunt a
saber-tooth tiger he had the Civil War
to get to
exactly chat said the Great Depression
productivity at an all-time
high that's so good right I'd like to
ask him about the Great Depression I
mean what do we do about
that I know why the great deis happened
everyone was too damn lazy they're too
damn lazy and too damn woke as you as
everybody well knows during the Great
defici nobody wanted to
work just lazy because they were
constantly taking action if you're
constantly taking action you yeah being
enslaved only made me hustle harder Gary
ve he's so
awesome we get
depressed I love
him I look forward to speaking with him
truly I do I I'm genuinely curious I
think he might I think he's a good kid
frankly he's just looking for a place to
belong he's looking for he's looking for
meaning he's
looking for anything out there you know
is there anybody out there he's a he's a
he's a bloke you
know in the doc number eight I don't
think you guys watch that one yet it's
pretty good is there anybody home
defending hust you I got it I just want
to rewatch The same ones we watched want
to say something all right here we go
McDonald's is a pyramid scheme oh
I'm ready for this that's what you think
yeah that's what you think # Hustlers
University drop in the Middle East I'll
make
peace here we go just want to say
something to all the people that keep
calling the real world a pyramid scheme
so when you join the real world there's
18 different huh when you join the real
world is that a ref to something or is
he just talking about life Matrix
getting out of school like school isn't
the real world it's a pyramid scheme
that's an interesting Theory actually I
don't know right and one of them is
affiliate marke which they use which is
like what you're doing right now take
content to teach you the fundamentals
the skills and everything you need to
know about affiliate marketing the
reason they use and to take content is
obviously because it is him who's
created it but also the fact that it's
easiest to do with that content really
is right now they're also giving a
billion views students 50% Commission of
every sale they made so we're getting
50% of the commission now you go to the
people what's good about this
one I I'm very curious where he's going
with this genuinely
ien what AB I think it's an epic take
he's saying that husters University type
is not a scam but McDonald's is the
real he didn't even mention
McDonald's the video he's running out of
time my man is spitting right now let
him go work noral jobs like for example
McDonald's let's say you're working in
McDonald's and the company is getting
£2,000 an hour and let's say you're
earning £12 an hour at McDonald's all
right I'm closing the Socialist yeah I
was about to say this kid yo wait no let
him go let him go no no no no no
no none of
this between 0.5 and 1% commission and
you are going to sit there say that the
real world or the hostage University is
a pyramid
scheme so my man said capitalism is the
ultimate pyramid scheme he goes I mean
kind of spitting yeah although I don't
know why he's using it to justify why
Andrew Tate is dope yeah I don't that
was a weird twist yeah but I mean power
of the people you know what I mean Jake
you're right there brother you you know
let's lock
arms for social democ
y oh we love that video does make me
think that we can help him though I do
think genuinely I feel like he he sees
something wrong with the world but he's
having a hard time uh uh squaring the
circle with uh some of his problematic
faves like Andrew Tate absolutely you
know and and he's not alone there's a
lot of people like out there out him
sure and like I I can be that I can be
that Father Figure yeah can you just do
it without being so feminine all
the
time I I don't know I need to find out
what he meant by
that just look at him just look at
him okay I guess it's so God we've been
doing a long episode
huh uh yeah 3 hours 34 minutes 58 power
of being on time
hey welcome thank you
[Music]
everybody
let's go let's go let's go we did it we
did it we did it it's Monday we put out
a whole another
video did you know that Andrew Tate he's
on this weird
[Music]
um he's like full supporting
like Gaza or what I mean obviously but
he's like a he's UND doing this whole
thing
about he's like donating money to Gaza
and then plugging his university it's
really crazy cuz you know he's like
Muslim now all right but he music play
in the maybe we can show it on on uh
maybe tomorrow Wednesday but he's on
some he's on some interesting right
all right we'll check it out
yeah peace to Gaza we love Gaza we love
the Palestinian
people Freedom end to the genocide
Happening by settler
lunatics
genocidal
Freaks and BB and Netanyahu B is a war
criminal he should be in
[Music]
jail